This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. In 1971, a 17-year-old girl won the Miss Black Tennessee Beauty Pageant. It set in motion a chain of events that would transform not just her life, but the lives of millions of other people. Born into poverty to a teenage mother in rural Mississippi, Oprah Winfrey had endured a difficult childhood. She bounced between relatives, experienced abuse, and left home at 13. The pageant became the first domino in a series of extraordinary events.
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。1971年，一位17岁的女孩赢得了田纳西州黑人小姐选美大赛。这一事件引发了一连串的连锁反应，不仅改变了她的人生，也改变了数百万人的生活。奥普拉·温弗瑞出生在密西西比州农村，母亲是一位十几岁的少女，她从小生活贫困，童年充满艰辛。她在亲戚间辗转寄居，遭受过虐待，并在13岁时离家出走。那场选美比赛成了她非凡人生中倒下的第一块多米诺骨牌。
Her win caught the attention of WVOL, a local radio station. It offered her a part-time news position. At 19, Oprah became Nashville's first female African-American news anchor. She then moved to Baltimore for television news and eventually to Chicago, where she transformed a struggling morning show into the Oprah Winfrey show. I'm Oprah Winfrey, and that's what we're talking about. Then came a production company, a magazine, a book club, and eventually her own television network. Oprah Winfrey became a billionaire, a household name.
她的胜出引起了当地广播电台WVOL的注意，并为她提供了一份兼职新闻工作。19岁时，奥普拉成为了纳什维尔第一位非裔美国女性新闻主播。随后，她搬到巴尔的摩从事电视新闻工作，最终来到芝加哥，在那里她将一档收视低迷的晨间节目改造成了《奥普拉·温弗瑞秀》。我是奥普拉·温弗瑞，这就是我们今天要讨论的话题。紧接着，她创办了制作公司、杂志、读书俱乐部，最终拥有了自己的电视网。奥普拉·温弗瑞成为了亿万富翁，家喻户晓。
For millions of people, she was the American dream made real. Can you see how each opportunity created momentum for the next? How each win opened doors that were previously closed. As the saying goes, nothing succeeds like success. But if good things can build on one another, if success can lead to more success, can the same thing happen the other way around? Can setback lead to setback, failure to failure? Can one door that is close to you turn into an endless series of obstacles?
对数百万人来说，她是美国梦的化身。你能看出每一个机会是如何为下一个机会积蓄动力的吗？每一个成功又是如何打开了原本关闭的大门？俗话说，没有什么比成功更能带来成功。但如果好事可以相互促进，如果成功可以带来更多的成功，那么反过来是否也成立呢？挫折是否会导致更多的挫折，失败是否会导致更多的失败？一扇对你关闭的门是否会变成无穷无尽的障碍？
Perhaps you know people who have experienced such downward spirals. Perhaps you have experienced this yourself. The cost of downward spirals are felt most acutely by the people who experience them. But all of us are made poorer by them. How many operas do we not have today because some domino in the distant past took a spill in the wrong direction? This week on Hidden Brain and in a companion story on Hidden Brain Plus, we explore the psychology of downward spirals and how our minds can set us up for failure or success.
也许你认识经历过这种恶性循环的人。也许你自己也经历过。恶性循环的代价，对于身处其中的人来说感受最为深刻。但我们所有人都因此变得更加贫穷。如果过去某个遥远的时刻，某块多米诺骨牌倒向了错误的方向，那么今天我们是不是就少了许多像奥普拉这样的人？本周在《Hidden Brain》节目以及《Hidden Brain Plus》的配套故事中，我们将探讨恶性循环的心理学，以及我们的思维如何让我们陷入失败或走向成功。
It's the kick-off to a month-long series about the mental obstacles we face when we try to achieve a goal or start a new chapter in our lives. Perhaps you have a New Year's resolution for yourself. Maybe you're struggling to keep your momentum on a work or personal project. Whatever your goal, we're going to examine why we derail our best laid plans and how to stay on track. When it rains, it pours. One bad thing is often followed by another. Your cat jumps up on the breakfast table and spills your coffee on your lap.
这是一个为期一个月的系列节目的开篇，旨在探讨当我们试图实现目标或开启人生新篇章时所面临的心理障碍。也许你为自己制定了新年计划。也许你正在努力保持工作或个人项目的动力。无论你的目标是什么，我们都将剖析为什么我们总是破坏自己精心制定的计划，以及如何保持正轨。祸不单行。一件坏事往往紧接着另一件坏事。你的猫跳上早餐桌，把咖啡洒在了你的腿上。
In a bad mood as you drive to work, you end up having a fender bender. Stressed out and distracted, you now tune out during an important meeting, which hurts your chances of getting that big promotion. The world seems to be conspiring against you. Sometimes, these downward spirals are just a bad day. But other times, they can grow bigger, much bigger. You can find yourself in a relationship that grows toxic or a job you hate. Addiction, depression, and financial trouble can follow.
开车去上班时心情糟糕，结果发生了轻微追尾。压力大且心不在焉的你，在一次重要会议上走神了，这损害了你获得大晋升的机会。世界似乎在与你作对。有时，这些恶性循环只是因为倒霉的一天。但有时，它们会变得更大，严重得多。你可能会发现自己陷入了一段有毒的关系，或者一份你讨厌的工作中。随之而来的可能是成瘾、抑郁和经济困境。
At Stanford University, Greg Walton studies the mental factors that set us up for failure and wise psychological interventions that can turn us towards success. Greg Walton, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Greg, I want to start by talking about self-fulfilling prophecies. When you were a kid growing up in Michigan, you and your family would often go canoeing. Now, I understand that you spent quite a bit of time in boats
在斯坦福大学，格雷格·沃尔顿研究那些导致我们失败的心理因素，以及能够引导我们走向成功的明智心理干预措施。格雷格·沃尔顿，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。非常感谢邀请我。格雷格，我想从“自我实现的预言”谈起。当你小时候在密歇根州长大时，你和家人经常去划独木舟。据我了解，你花了不少时间在船上，
and you were a fairly skilled paddler? Yes, it was like one of the big family activities we did. Almost every summer we would go on a lot of. canoe trip often in far northern Ontario and on big rivers. It was something that I love to do and I love to do as part of our family. I understand that you once took a canoe trip with your father on the Sturgeon River. I don't think I have ever visited. What is this river like? Yeah, so this is a story that he loves to tell because I am the one who am the victim of it. this is a small river in the northern part of the lower peninsula of Michigan. It's a fast and
而且你还是个相当熟练的划手？是的，这是我们家的大型家庭活动之一。几乎每年夏天我们都会去进行很多次独木舟旅行，通常是在安大略省北部和一些大河上。这是我喜欢做的事情，也是我们家庭活动的一部分。据我了解，你曾经和父亲在鲟鱼河上进行过一次独木舟旅行。我想我从未去过那里。那条河是什么样的？是的，这是一个他很喜欢讲的故事，因为我是其中的受害者。这是密歇根州下半岛北部的一条小河。它是一条快速且
windy river, a small quick river. And the outfitter tells you when you're renting the canoes from them that most people flip the boat on the river at one time or another. And the river is quick. It turns quickly. There's lots of overhanging branches, lots of overhanging, lots of trees that have fallen in the river that you have to dodge. The water goes through those rushes very fast. And if you hit them in the wrong way, the boat can turn sideways and you can fill the boat. And there you are having an unplanned swim. So the outfitter who was walking you through this described something called sweepers. I'm not much of a paddler myself. Can you describe what a sweeper is, Greg? Yeah. So if you imagine a river that's making a turn and the water is rushing through the outside
蜿蜒的河流，一条又小又急的河。当你从租赁商那里租独木舟时，他们会告诉你，大多数人迟早会在河里翻船。这条河水流很快，转弯也很急。有很多悬垂的树枝，有很多悬垂的树木倒在河里，你必须躲避。水流穿过这些障碍物时速度非常快。如果你撞击它们的方式不对，船可能会侧翻，导致船舱进水。然后你就不得不进行一次计划外的游泳。所以，带你熟悉情况的租赁商描述了一种叫做“扫荡者”（sweepers）的东西。我自己不太会划船。格雷格，你能描述一下什么是“扫荡者”吗？是的。如果你想象一条正在转弯的河流，水流正猛烈地冲过转弯的外侧，
part of that turn, and then a tree is overhanging that outside part of the turn. So the branches come all the way down to the water. The river can sweep through very quickly, but the boat can't. The boat will get caught in the branches. So if you're in the main flow of the current and you're in that outside flow and you hit the tree, then you are held up, but the water keeps going. And that's a recipe for disaster. So the outfitter has basically warned you about the river.
然后一棵树悬垂在转弯的外侧。树枝一直延伸到水面。河水可以很快地流过，但船不行。船会被树枝卡住。所以，如果你处于主流中，并且处于外侧水流中，撞上了树，那么你就会被卡住，但水流还在继续。这就是灾难的根源。所以租赁商基本上已经警告过你关于这条河的情况。
It has these sharp turns with these sweepers. And your family is setting out. I understand that you're in the boat with your. our dad. And did you exchange any notes before you set out on this journey? Yeah, our goal was to avoid the sweepers, right? So when we see the current sweeping around through the left side and these branches hanging down, we're going to stay to the inside of those curves so that we don't get caught in the branches. And as we went down the river, we saw boat after boat, you know, caught, caught in those branches. And what happened? Did you get caught as well? We missed every sweeper. I felt very proud of
它有这些急转弯和“扫荡者”。你们一家人出发了。据我了解，你和你的父亲在同一条船上。在出发前你们交流过什么注意事项吗？是的，我们的目标是避开“扫荡者”，对吧？所以当我们看到水流向左侧扫过，树枝垂下来时，我们会保持在弯道的内侧，这样就不会被树枝卡住。当我们顺流而下时，我们看到一艘又一艘船被卡在那些树枝里。发生了什么？你们也被卡住了吗？我们避开了每一个“扫荡者”。我感到非常自豪，
myself. I was 10 years old, and I felt like I was an accomplished canoeist. So you're sitting at the front of the boat. Your dad is sitting at the back. You've made it through most of these sweepers. You must be feeling pretty triumphant at this point. I'm feeling great. And then we get to this little normal curve with no branches in sight, not even especially fast water, and the boat is moving to the right, and I feel a little jostle to the left. And the words of the outfitter came to my mind, 80% of people take an unplanned swim. And so I kind of put those two parts together and I was like, we're going down. I'm getting out of the way.
我当时10岁，我觉得自己是一个很有成就的独木舟手。所以你坐在船头，你父亲坐在船尾。你们已经避开了大部分“扫荡者”。此时你一定感到非常得意。我感觉棒极了。然后我们到了一个普通的小弯道，视线内没有树枝，水流也不是特别快，船正在向右移动，我感觉到左边有一点晃动。租赁商的话浮现在我的脑海中：80%的人会进行一次计划外的游泳。于是我把这两部分联系起来，心想：我们要翻船了。我得避开。
So I decided to jump out of the boat to get out of the way as the boat capsized. And of course, that's what flipped the boat. Wait, so now you're in the water. Did your dad go in the water as well? I'm in the water. my dad's into water, our stuff is all floating downstream, my dad is sputtering at me, very upset. We end up losing like a life jacket and a spare paddle. We spend 45 minutes retrieving our stuff and drying out.
所以我决定跳出船，在船倾覆时避开它。当然，这正是导致船翻的原因。等等，所以现在你掉进水里了。你父亲也掉进水里了吗？我掉进水里了，我父亲也掉进水里了，我们的东西都顺流而下，我父亲对我大发雷霆，非常生气。我们最终丢失了一件救生衣和一个备用桨。我们花了45分钟才找回我们的东西并晾干。
Everybody's laughing at me. Years later, after Greg became a psychologist, it became clear to him what happened that day. The problem was not the river. The problem was inside his own. head. So I had the idea planted in my mind that things were going to go wrong. And then I was looking out for the moment when they might go wrong. And as soon as I saw that moment, I was like, is going wrong? And I acted. And of course, the acting is what made it go wrong. So this reminds me of that classic study by the great psychologist Daniel Wagner called
每个人都在嘲笑我。多年后，格雷格成为了一名心理学家，他清楚地明白了那天发生了什么。问题不在于河流，问题在于他自己的脑子里。所以我脑子里种下了“事情会出错”的想法。然后我一直在寻找可能出错的时刻。一旦我看到那个时刻，我就想：是不是要出错了？然后我采取了行动。当然，正是这种行动导致了错误。这让我想起了伟大的心理学家丹尼尔·韦格纳的一项经典研究，叫做
the White Bear Experiment. Describe what this study was, Greg. Yeah. But, um, But Professor Wagner did was ask people not to think about a white bear and then write down their thoughts in a kind of stream of consciousness, like what they're thinking about for several minutes. And he finds that almost everybody references a white bear, even though that's the one thing that they're specifically not supposed to be thinking about, that the act of suppressing it, trying to not think about it, actually calls it to mind. I mean, even as we are talking right now, I feel like I can see a ton of white bears walking
“白熊实验”。格雷格，描述一下这项研究。是的，韦格纳教授要求人们不要去想一只白熊，然后写下他们的想法，这是一种意识流，比如他们几分钟内想到的东西。他发现几乎每个人都提到了白熊，尽管这是他们被明确要求不要去想的事情，即压抑它的行为，试图不去想它，实际上反而让它浮现在脑海中。我的意思是，即使我们现在正在交谈，我也觉得我能看到成吨的白熊走过
across my mindscape right now. Exactly, right? Don't think about it. And then there it is. You can't help but think about it. So sometimes the boat flips because the current is too strong or we're not skilled enough, but sometimes our own minds can set us up for failure. Make the connection for me between your story in the boat and the white bear study. Yeah. So I hear the message that most people flip. And I could be trying to suppress that the whole time. We're not going to flip. We're not going to flip. It's not going to happen to us. We're good. We're better canoeists than these other people. I know the J-stroke. My father knows the J-stroke. We're not going to flip. But the very active trying to suppress that thought keeps it active in your mind. It makes it available. It doesn't
我的脑海。完全正确，对吧？不要去想它。然后它就在那里了。你忍不住去想它。所以有时船翻是因为水流太强或者我们技术不够，但有时我们自己的思维会让我们陷入失败。帮我把你在船上的故事和白熊研究联系起来。是的。所以我听到了大多数人会翻船的消息。我可能一直在试图压抑这个想法。我们不会翻船。我们不会翻船。这不会发生在我们身上。我们很好。我们比其他人是更好的独木舟手。我知道J型划法。我父亲知道J型划法。我们不会翻船。但试图压抑这个想法的行为本身，让它在你的脑海中保持活跃。它让它变得触手可及。这并不
mean that it's going to get acted upon. But then when the boat moved in a direction I didn't expect, it became a way to understand that movement. What's happening here? Oh, we're about to flip like I was worried we might. And then I take action and response. And so I think often in life, the things that are preoccupying us, the things that we might be trying to suppress are these negative contingencies, the relationship that doesn't go the way that you want,
意味着它一定会发生。但当船向我没预料到的方向移动时，它就成了理解那种移动的一种方式。这里发生了什么？哦，我们要翻船了，就像我担心的那样。然后我采取了行动。所以我认为在生活中，那些让我们心烦意乱的事情，那些我们可能试图压抑的事情，往往是这些负面的偶然事件，比如不顺心的关系，
the test that doesn't go the way that you want, the failure that might happen. So in some ways what you're saying is that as we have these worries in our heads, our minds are preoccupied with these worries, but then we also become vulnerable to seeing evidence that the worry might actually be real when we look at evidence that might or might not actually be real. Yeah. So it's like the worry is a kind of hypothesis, a kind of fearful hypothesis about how the world might be. It might be like this. Maybe this person doesn't really love me. Maybe I'm not. not good at this. Maybe I don't belong here. And those are leading questions that we use to interrogate our experience, that we read the world through the lens of. And I think it happens to all of us. I think it happens all the time. And I think it's partly a consequence of our kind of default response of trying to suppress these thoughts and not to contend with
没考好的试，可能发生的失败。所以从某种程度上说，你是在说，当我们脑子里有这些担忧时，我们的思维被这些担忧占据了，但当我们寻找证据时，我们也会变得容易认为这些担忧可能是真实的，即使这些证据可能并不真实。是的。所以这就像担忧是一种假设，一种关于世界可能如何运作的恐惧假设。它可能是这样的。也许这个人并不真正爱我。也许我不擅长这个。也许我不属于这里。这些是我们用来审视我们经历的引导性问题，我们通过这些视角来解读世界。我认为这发生在我们所有人身上。我认为这经常发生。而且我认为这在某种程度上是我们试图压抑这些想法，而不是以诚实的方式去面对它们的结果。
them in an honest way. When we come back, habits of mind that can set us on the path of downward spirals and how we can pull ourselves out. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Sometimes, when we expect the worst, the worst is exactly what we get. We tell ourselves a story, I'm not good enough, I'm not smart enough, and then we go looking for evidence to back up our beliefs.
休息之后，我们将探讨那些让我们陷入恶性循环的思维习惯，以及我们如何才能摆脱它们。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。有时，当我们期待最坏的情况时，最坏的情况恰恰就会发生。我们告诉自己一个故事：我不够好，我不够聪明，然后我们去寻找证据来支持我们的信念。
Sure enough, we find what we are looking for. But self-fulfilling prophecies are not the only reason we get in our own way. At Stanford University, psychologist Greg Walton says a number of factors can lead to downward spirals. Greg, the psychologist Sandra Murray once ran a study that looked at how couples can get into relationship trouble. The study had a very clever design. Can you describe it for me? I can. Yeah, this is one of my favorite all-time studies. So Sandra Murray brought couples into a lab. These are dating couples. and she gave them a situation where she has them at separate desks in the same room,
果然，我们找到了我们正在寻找的东西。但自我实现的预言并不是我们阻碍自己的唯一原因。在斯坦福大学，心理学家格雷格·沃尔顿说，许多因素都可能导致恶性循环。格雷格，心理学家桑德拉·默里曾经做过一项研究，观察夫妻如何陷入关系困境。这项研究的设计非常巧妙。你能为我描述一下吗？可以。是的，这是我最喜欢的历史研究之一。桑德拉·默里把夫妻带进实验室。这些是正在约会的情侣，
and she asks them each to write about all of the things about their partner that they dislike. And in the first condition, both people do this. Both people write for 30 seconds or a minute or a minute and a half, both finish, and then they're all done, and everybody's okay. But in the second condition, one member of the couple is going through that task. they're writing all the things that they don't like about their partner, but their partners asked, unbeknownst to the first person, to do something different. The partners ask to list all of the objects that are in their apartment or house. So imagine you're the first person.
她给他们安排了一个情境，让他们在同一个房间里坐在不同的桌子旁，她要求他们每个人写下关于伴侣他们不喜欢的所有事情。在第一种情况下，两个人都会这样做。两个人写30秒、一分钟或一分钟半，两人都写完了，然后就结束了，每个人都没事。但在第二种情况下，其中一个人正在经历那个任务，他们写下所有他们不喜欢伴侣的事情，但他们的伴侣被要求（在第一人不知情的情况下）做一些不同的事情。伴侣被要求列出他们公寓或房子里的所有物品。所以想象一下你是第一个人。
You jot down a couple of annoyances you have with your partner, but your partner is writing on and on as if one thought automatically leads to the next and you can't stop like this, that, oh my God, it's like never going to end. Like what are they writing? of course, because they're listing all the objects in their house, that list is going to go on much, much longer than the first person's list, which is just describing the things that they dislike. It's infinite, right? There's an infinite number of things, it seems your partner has a problem with you about. What was the effect on the couples of doing this study, Greg? So what Murray was interested in was how self-esteem functions in relationships. And so self-esteem
你写下了一些对伴侣的烦恼，但你的伴侣却一直在写，好像一个想法自动引出下一个，你停不下来，像这样，那个，天哪，这好像永远写不完。他们到底在写什么？当然，因为他们是在列出房子里的所有物品，那个清单会比第一个人的清单长得多，第一个人只是在描述他们不喜欢的事情。它是无限的，对吧？看起来你的伴侣对你有无数的问题。格雷格，这项研究对夫妻有什么影响？默里感兴趣的是自尊在关系中是如何运作的。所以自尊
is like, how much do you like yourself? How good of a person do you think you are? How worthy do you think you are. And lots of research shows that when people have lower self-esteem, they can wonder whether they're truly admirable, whether their partner could truly respect them, truly, truly love them. And so they have a kind of uncertainty about their partner's regard. And what Murray finds is that for people who have low self-esteem who go through this situation, it triggers them in a variety of ways. And they end up responding by kind of derogating their partner. They feel less close to them, and they start to distance themselves from the partner. It's the start of a kind of downward relationship spiral. So in other words, if you and I were a couple, and I see you
就像，你有多喜欢你自己？你认为自己是一个多好的人？你认为自己有多值得？大量研究表明，当人们自尊心较低时，他们会怀疑自己是否真的值得钦佩，伴侣是否真的能尊重他们，是否真的、真的爱他们。所以他们对伴侣的看法有一种不确定性。默里发现，对于那些自尊心较低且经历这种情况的人来说，它以各种方式触发了他们。他们最终通过贬低伴侣来回应。他们感到与伴侣不那么亲近，并开始疏远伴侣。这是一场关系恶性循环的开始。所以换句话说，如果你和我是一对情侣，我看到你
writing endlessly about me, and I think you're writing about all the reasons that you dislike me, you're saying that if I have low self-esteem, I now react negatively towards you. I start to derogate you and think less of you? Yeah, it's a self-defense mechanism. You're trying to protect yourself by derogating this partner who seems to be derogating you. So low self-esteem can lead us
不停地写关于我的事情，我以为你在写所有你不喜欢我的原因，你是说如果我自尊心低，我现在就会对你产生负面反应？我开始贬低你，看轻你？是的，这是一种自我防御机制。你试图通过贬低这个似乎在贬低你的伴侣来保护自己。所以低自尊会导致我们
to come to conclusions about how others perceive us, and this can have a negative effect on the relationship itself. I'm curious how this shows up in other domains. You've studied a concept called belonging uncertainty. What is belonging uncertainty, Greg? Yeah, belonging uncertainty is a persistent worry or unsettledness about your belonging in an important space, like a school space or a workspace. And all of us can have this kind of feeling.
得出关于他人如何看待我们的结论，这会对关系本身产生负面影响。我很好奇这在其他领域是如何表现的。你研究过一个概念叫“归属感不确定性”。格雷格，什么是归属感不确定性？是的，归属感不确定性是对你在重要空间（如学校空间或工作空间）中的归属感的一种持续担忧或不安。我们所有人都会有这种感觉。
All of us can wonder whether we belong in a new school environment, for example. But those worries can be particularly pervasive and profound when we're going into a setting where your group is underrepresented, where it hasn't been welcome in the past, where maybe there's a history of exclusion or discrimination. So, for example, if you think about a woman going into a male-dominated profession, if you think about a student of color going into a university setting that hasn't historically welcomed large numbers of students of color, where it seems like the institution is built for and of other people, other kinds of people, then it's very easy to wonder, do I belong here? Could people like me belong here?
我们所有人都会怀疑自己是否属于一个新的学校环境，例如。但当我们要进入一个你的群体代表性不足、过去不受欢迎、或者可能存在排斥或歧视历史的环境时，这些担忧可能会特别普遍和深刻。例如，如果你想到一个女性进入一个男性主导的职业，如果你想到一个有色人种学生进入一个历史上没有欢迎过大量有色人种学生的大学环境，在那里似乎机构是为其他人、其他类型的人建立的，那么很容易怀疑：我属于这里吗？像我这样的人能属于这里吗？
Hmm. So if I feel like I'm an outsider in my workplace or my school, does it make it easier for me to jump to conclusion? So if a co-worker forgets to copy me on an email, for example, is it possible that I then assume that they think I'm not important or not competent or not welcome? Yeah. So it's a lot like the self-esteem study where there's an ambiguous event. In this case, you don't know what your partner is writing, but they seem to be writing on and on. You know, in a school setting, for example, students might reach out to a professor and maybe they don't get a response from the professor. Maybe they ask a question in class and they don't like how it's received. Maybe they get a poor grade on an early assignment. Maybe they try to join a student group and the student group doesn't want them there. Maybe friends in their dorm go out and don't invite them to that social outing. So there's all sorts of events that happen on a daily basis in a school environment, high school environment, a college environment, and also in work environments.
嗯。所以如果我觉得我在工作场所或学校是个局外人，这是否会让我更容易跳到结论？例如，如果同事忘记在邮件中抄送我，我是否会假设他们认为我不重要、不称职或不受欢迎？是的。这很像自尊研究，其中有一个模棱两可的事件。在这种情况下，你不知道你的伴侣在写什么，但他们似乎一直在写。你知道，在学校环境中，例如，学生可能会联系教授，也许他们没有得到教授的回应。也许他们在课堂上问了一个问题，他们不喜欢它被接收的方式。也许他们在早期的作业中得到了很差的分数。也许他们试图加入一个学生团体，而学生团体不想要他们。也许宿舍里的朋友出去玩，没有邀请他们参加社交活动。所以每天在学校环境、高中环境、大学环境以及工作环境中都会发生各种各样的事件。
And people are reading those events from the perspective of the question, do people like me belong here? And when that question is on the mind, it seems like every event might be further evidence of a negative conclusion. So it's almost like there's a referendum taking place on that anxiety in your mind. And you say, my coworker didn't copy me on this email or my friends in my dorm didn't invite me out, that confirms my belief that, in fact, they don't want me here. Yeah, and ironically, it's particularly powerful in settings that people value, right? So, you go to a company, maybe you get a job at a company that you've long admired, that does work that you think is really important, and you're so honored and proud to be part of that
人们从“像我这样的人属于这里吗？”这个问题的角度来解读这些事件。当这个问题在脑海中时，似乎每一个事件都可能是负面结论的进一步证据。所以这几乎就像你的脑海中正在对那种焦虑进行全民公投。你说，我的同事没有在邮件中抄送我，或者我宿舍里的朋友没有邀请我出去，这证实了我的信念，即事实上，他们不想要我在这里。是的，讽刺的是，它在人们重视的环境中特别强大，对吧？所以，你去一家公司，也许你在一家你长期钦佩的公司找到了一份工作，它做着你认为非常重要的事情，你感到非常荣幸和自豪能成为那家公司的一部分，
company, but you're also worried about whether you and maybe people like you could belong there. And then these cues kind of build up over time. And every cue, you're reading from the perspective of, do I really belong here? Do people like me really belong here? Are you really going to be welcome and able to contribute and valued? And when that's the lens that you're taking on all these daily events, it can feel like the evidence is building. So in some ways, what we're doing is we are drawing. drawing more meaning than we should from a very small amount of information. You've come up with a
但你也担心你和像你这样的人是否能属于那里。然后这些线索随着时间的推移而积累。每一个线索，你都从“我真的属于这里吗？像我这样的人真的属于这里吗？你真的会受欢迎并能够做出贡献和被重视吗？”的角度来解读。当这是你解读所有日常事件的视角时，你会觉得证据在增加。所以从某种程度上说，我们正在从极少量的信息中得出比我们应该得出的更多的意义。你提出了一个
shorthand for our tendency to overreact to minuscule pieces of information. You call it a tiff bit. What is a tiff bit, Greg, and what's the origin of the phrase? Yeah, the tiff bit is a tiny fact with a big theory. And my experience on the canoe, where the boat shifted left, that was a tiny fact that I had a big theory about. But the phrase itself, it actually was developed by my brother and me. It came from a story my brother had. He was a musician for most of his 20s. He lived in New York City. And at one point, he started a relationship with a woman. And the relationship seemed to be going very well. It was going on for some months. And then after some time, they break up to his surprise, my brother's surprise. And he didn't
速记法，用来描述我们对微小信息过度反应的倾向。你称之为“Tiff bit”。格雷格，什么是“Tiff bit”，这个短语的起源是什么？是的，“Tiff bit”是一个带有大理论的小事实。我在独木舟上的经历，船向左移动，那是一个我有一个大理论的小事实。但这个短语本身，实际上是我哥哥和我开发的。它来自我哥哥的一个故事。他在20多岁的大部分时间里是一名音乐家。他住在纽约市。有一次，他开始和一个女人建立关系。这段关系似乎进行得非常好。持续了几个月。然后过了一段时间，他们分手了，令他惊讶，令我哥哥惊讶。他没有
see this coming. And so they're having the breakup conversation. So my brother asks her, you know, like what happened here? Like what, why is this? Why is this? Why is this? going down this way. And she says, do you remember that time we went to Macy's? And my brother remembers an uneventful trip to Macy's. He says, yeah, I remember we went to Macy's. And she said, I had to tell you to tuck your shirt in. I can't be with you. She breaks up with him because his shirt was not tucked in? Yeah, she breaks up with him because his shirt was not And like, the question is, what does that represent for her? Like, what was the meaning that that had for her about who he was, who she was, what their relationship was, what its trajectory
预见到这一点。所以他们正在进行分手谈话。所以我哥哥问她，你知道，发生了什么事？为什么会这样？为什么会这样？为什么会这样？走向这个方向。她说，你还记得我们去梅西百货的那次吗？我哥哥记得一次平淡无奇的梅西百货之旅。他说，是的，我记得我们去了梅西百货。她说，我不得不告诉你把衬衫塞进去。我不能和你在一起。她因为他的衬衫没塞进去而和他分手？是的，她因为他的衬衫没塞进去而和他分手。就像，问题是，这对她来说代表了什么？就像，那对他是什么人、她是什么人、他们的关系是什么、它的轨迹是什么，有什么意义？
was? That was entirely a mystery. But, you know, we called that a tiff bit, a tiny fact, a big theory. There's something tiny, but you have a big theory about it. And I don't want to tell that story in a way that makes fun of the woman in the story. I want to tell that story because I want to encourage all of us to attend to the circumstances where you or the people around you seem to be drawing a large meaning from something that's objectively small. When we do that, it's a clue that there's something big under the surface, something big psychological, something big about who you are or who you can be or who another person is. And if you can use that TIFBit to interrogate that and to understand that and to surface, that question that's on the table, you're going to be able to function much more effectively. So you had an experience in your own life, Greg, where you didn't interrogate your own TIFPIT.
那完全是个谜。但是，你知道，我们称之为“Tiff bit”，一个小事实，一个大理论。有一些微小的东西，但你对它有一个大理论。我不想以嘲笑故事中的女人的方式讲述那个故事。我想讲述那个故事，因为我想鼓励我们所有人关注那些你或你周围的人似乎从客观上很小的事情中得出巨大意义的情况。当我们这样做时，这是一个线索，表明表面下有一些大的东西，一些大的心理层面的东西，一些关于你是谁、你可以成为谁或另一个人是谁的大东西。如果你能利用那个“Tiff bit”来审视它，去理解它，去浮现那个摆在桌面上的问题，你将能够更有效地运作。所以你在自己的生活中也有过一次经历，格雷格，你没有审视你自己的“Tiff bit”。
I understand that you were in college and you came to a rather sweeping conclusion about a famous fast food chain? Yeah, it wasn't really about the fast food chain so much as it's patrons. So I was brought up in Michigan, and I went to college in California at Stanford. And the first year of college and the first quarter at Stanford, somehow an in-and-out truck, a truck from the chain in-and-out, showed up on campus. And there was this long line of students, and I assumed that they were all from Southern California, all in line, all eager to get a burger, all very happy. And I look at these people as I'm coming back from class, and I think, I'm not standing in line for it. burger, like, screw that, and I like march off to the dining hall and I eat my lunch alone. And it took me many years to understand like what it was that was actually going through my mind
据我了解，你在大学时，对一家著名的快餐连锁店得出了一个相当笼统的结论？是的，这与其说是关于快餐连锁店，不如说是关于它的顾客。我在密歇根州长大，我在加利福尼亚州的斯坦福大学上大学。大学第一年和斯坦福大学的第一个季度，不知何故，一辆In-N-Out卡车，来自In-N-Out连锁店的卡车，出现在校园里。有一长队学生，我以为他们都来自南加州，都在排队，都渴望买汉堡，都非常高兴。我下课回来时看着这些人，我想，我才不排队买汉堡呢，去他的，然后我径直走向食堂，独自吃午饭。我花了很多年才明白当时我脑子里到底在想什么。
at that time. But what I came to understand was that I was just profoundly homesick. I was really far from home. It felt like a really different place. These people from Southern California seemed so different. I felt excluded from the burger party and I felt excluded from like, the social scene, like maybe I didn't belong with these kinds of people. And I had no real awareness of that at the time. I didn't understand that. I didn't understand that those feelings of belonging uncertainty were normal, that everybody would experience them, that probably the people from Southern California were having their own version of that experience too. And if I'd had that awareness, I could have been much more effective. I could have gotten in line. I could ask some kid
但后来我明白的是，我只是非常想家。我离家真的很远。这感觉像是一个非常不同的地方。这些来自南加州的人看起来太不同了。我感到被排除在汉堡派对之外，我感到被排除在社交圈之外，也许我不属于这类人。当时我对此没有任何真正的意识。我不明白这一点。我不明白那些归属感不确定性的感觉是正常的，每个人都会经历它们，可能来自南加州的人也有他们自己版本的经历。如果我有那种意识，我可以更有效。我可以排队。我可以问某个孩子，
maybe from Irvine, hey, like, what's in and out? And I'm sure, he would have said, in and out, I love it and out. I went to in and out all the time. And you got to get it with animal style. And I'd say, what's animal style? And he'd tell me what animal style is. And I would have had a good interaction. And I would have felt connected to somebody who was different for me and coming from a different place. And that would have been a sort of belonging supportive experience. But I was unable to do that because I was unaware of my own feelings. And I was unaware of my own feelings. And I was unaware. of how normal those feelings were. So then I just kind of fled. You know, what's striking here is that as you saw this long line of people at this burger truck, I mean, this is completely innocuous. Obviously, the people standing in line are not trying to exclude you from the school. They're not thinking of you.
也许来自尔湾，嘿，In-N-Out是什么？我相信他会说，In-N-Out，我爱In-N-Out。我一直去In-N-Out。你必须点“动物风味”（animal style）。我会说，什么是“动物风味”？他会告诉我什么是“动物风味”。我会有一个很好的互动。我会感到与一个与我不同、来自不同地方的人建立了联系。那将是一种支持归属感的体验。但我无法做到这一点，因为我没有意识到自己的感受。我没有意识到自己的感受。我没有意识到这些感受是多么正常。所以我只是逃跑了。你知道，这里引人注目的是，当你看到汉堡卡车前排着长队时，我的意思是，这完全是无害的。显然，排队的人并不是试图把你排除在学校之外。他们没有想到你。
They're not even aware that you are there. you are reading all of this into the fact that there's this long line of people, and you don't know why there's this long line of people in front of the truck. And as you point out, the tiny fact is magnified because it's tapping into your underlying doubts and insecurities. And so in some ways, we are gathering a bunch of these tiny facts and then weave them into these larger stories. So perhaps one day it's, you know, nobody's inviting me to the in-and-out burger truck. The next day, it's something else. Psychologists sometimes call this mental calcification.
他们甚至不知道你在那里。你把所有这些都读进了“有一长队人”这个事实中，你不知道为什么卡车前有这么长的一队人。正如你指出的，小事实被放大了，因为它触及了你潜在的怀疑和不安全感。所以从某种程度上说，我们正在收集一堆这些小事实，然后把它们编织成这些更大的故事。所以也许有一天是，你知道，没有人邀请我去In-N-Out汉堡卡车。第二天，是别的事情。心理学家有时称之为“心理钙化”。
What does this idea mean, Greg? Yeah, so it's like when you go from a question to a belief to an almost axiom. So there's a question of belonging. Like, am I going to belong here? Will people like me belong here? Will I fit in with these people who are from this different background to a belief that I don't, to the kind of axiomatic version of that belief? And it's not just a mental calcification.
格雷格，这个想法是什么意思？是的，就像当你从一个问题变成一个信念，再变成一个几乎是公理的东西。所以有一个归属感的问题。比如，我会属于这里吗？像我这样的人会属于这里吗？我会和这些来自不同背景的人合得来吗？到一个信念，即我不属于，到那种信念的公理化版本。这不仅仅是心理钙化。
It's a calcification in behavior and in patterns of relationships. So, you know, if I don't engage with the in-and-out truck and then I don't have a positive interaction, if you magnify that across all the different spaces, for example, of a college experience, I'm not having positive social interactions with peers. I'm not having positive social interactions with professors. I'm not engaging in the kinds of relationships that ultimately everybody needs to have a good experience in school and to grow in school. If you have a date and the date doesn't go well
这是行为和关系模式中的钙化。所以，你知道，如果我不参与In-N-Out卡车，然后我没有积极的互动，如果你把这一点放大到所有不同的空间，例如大学经历，我没有与同龄人进行积极的社交互动。我没有与教授进行积极的社交互动。我没有参与每个人最终都需要在学校获得良好体验和在学校成长的关系。如果你有一个约会，约会进行得不顺利，
and you think, I'm not lovable, and then you take that mindset to your next date and the next date goes terrible, like you've built a pattern of relationships, a pattern of interactions with other people that gets fixed. Almost like there's almost a, sometimes I think about it with an analogy with pottery,
你认为，我不讨人喜欢，然后你带着那种心态去参加下一次约会，下一次约会进行得非常糟糕，就像你建立了一种关系模式，一种与他人互动的模式，它变得固定了。几乎就像，有时我用陶器的类比来思考它，
like with clay, clay is very malleable. It's very malleable early on. You can shape it this way. You can shape it that way. But when you fire it, it gets fixed and it gets harder to change. Why do you think we extrapolate so much from small facts, Greg? Why is it that we have these small things happen to us?
就像粘土，粘土在早期是非常可塑的。你可以把它塑造成这样。你可以把它塑造成那样。但当你烧制它时，它就固定了，变得更难改变了。格雷格，你认为为什么我们从微小的事实中推断出这么多？为什么我们会有这些小事情发生在我们身上？
And we know in the past and we know from the lives of the people around us. We know when they exaggerate, you know, we know when our friends or partners, when they basically, you know, they dive off the deep end over something trivial. And we can see that they are over-interpreting sometimes. detail. It's much harder for us to see this in ourselves. Why do you think that is? I mean, there's lots of small facts that we don't overinterpret. But the ones that we do over interpret are the ones that are probing existential questions for a person. Like, can I belong
我们过去知道，我们从周围人的生活中知道。我们知道当他们夸大其词时，你知道，我们知道当我们的朋友或伴侣，当他们基本上，你知道，因为琐事而钻牛角尖时。我们可以看到他们有时在过度解读细节。我们很难在自己身上看到这一点。你认为为什么会这样？我的意思是，有很多小事实我们没有过度解读。但我们过度解读的那些是正在探测一个人存在主义问题的那些。比如，我能属于
in college? Or can I build, like, you fail a math test and you think, I'm dumb at math. I'll never be able to pursue my goal of going to medical school. These are existential questions. They define the course of your life, like whether you're going to be able to be and do who you want to be and do. And so then that's when we're really attuned, when we're really paying attention. That's when the small things seem to mean a lot. I remember when I was in middle school or high school, I was doing badly at math. And after a couple of tests where I did badly, the moment I encountered a problem that was
大学吗？或者我能建立，比如，你数学考试不及格，你认为，我数学很笨。我永远无法实现我上医学院的目标。这些是存在主义问题。它们决定了你的人生道路，比如你是否能够成为你想成为的人，做你想做的事。所以这就是我们真正关注的时候，当我们真正注意的时候。这就是小事情似乎意义重大的时候。我记得我在初中或高中时，我数学学得很差。在几次考试不及格后，当我遇到一个问题时，
difficult on the next math test, my mind said, well, of course, you're not going to to be able to solve this problem. You're not good at math. And in some ways, it's exactly the same pattern that you're just describing. Yeah, exactly. But it's worth noting that things like fixed mindset ideas about intelligence are literally taught in our culture. Like there's a whole history, a whole sociocultural history of how the idea that there's this quality called intelligence, that it differs very widely between different people, between different groups, that it can be assessed with short tests, that it can be determinative of a person's life Of course, this idea is deeply rooted within Western culture.
在下一次数学考试中很难，我的脑海里说，好吧，当然，你无法解决这个问题。你不擅长数学。从某种程度上说，这和你刚才描述的模式完全一样。是的，完全一样。但值得注意的是，像关于智力的固定心态想法在我们的文化中是字面上传授的。比如，有一整段历史，一整段社会文化历史，关于“智力”这种品质的想法，它在不同人之间、不同群体之间差异很大，它可以通过简短的测试来评估，它可以决定一个人的生活。当然，这个想法在西方文化中根深蒂固。
It's reflected in many institutional practices and many interpersonal practices, like praise, like, oh, you're so smart. And what that does is it sets people up for the kind of thought process that you're describing, where when you encounter some challenge, when you encounter some difficulty, you don't think, oh, like, I haven't got this yet, or maybe I need a different tact into this to understand this, or how else can I approach this? Instead, you think, my mind doesn't work that way. I'm not able to do this, and you check out.
它反映在许多制度实践和许多人际实践中，比如赞美，比如，哦，你真聪明。而这所做的是，它让人们陷入你所描述的那种思维过程，当你遇到一些挑战，当你遇到一些困难时，你不会想，哦，我还没掌握这个，或者也许我需要一种不同的策略来理解这个，或者我还能怎么处理这个？相反，你认为，我的大脑不是那样运作的。我无法做到这一点，然后你就放弃了。
So at one level, you can call this self-sabotage, but in some ways it's actually sadder than that because the person is not trying to sabotage themselves. They're trying, in fact, to fit in. They want to fit in. They want to do well at math. They want to be a good parent. They want to be healthy.
所以在某种程度上，你可以称之为自我破坏，但从某种程度上说，它实际上比那更令人悲伤，因为那个人并不是试图破坏自己。事实上，他们是在试图融入。他们想融入。他们想在数学上做得好。他们想成为一个好父母。他们想保持健康。
But in some ways, their minds are undermining what they want to do. Yeah, their minds are undermining what they want to do. and they're doing so often in a very reasonable way that comes from the social context itself. So, like, in the canoe story, the canoe outfitter said, most people take an unplanned dip. Like, that was actually, like, on their materials, right? You have a student who goes to gifted and talented programs, a student who's praised their whole life, that they're so smart, and then they have your experience in math, they get to seventh grade, they get to eighth grade, they get to 12th grade, whatever it is,
但在某种程度上，他们的思维正在破坏他们想做的事情。是的，他们的思维正在破坏他们想做的事情，而且他们这样做往往是以一种非常合理的方式，这种方式来自社会环境本身。所以，就像在独木舟故事中，独木舟租赁商说，大多数人会进行一次计划外的游泳。这实际上是在他们的材料上，对吧？你有一个学生去天才班，一个一生都被赞美很聪明的学生，然后他们在数学上有了你的经历，他们到了七年级，他们到了八年级，他们到了12年级，无论是什么，
and they counter something that's challenging, and they think, oh, maybe I don't have that magic ingredient that seems to be necessary for somebody to do this. Like, that idea was taught to people. Or if you want to think about belonging in college, like, there is a very literal history of racial, ethnic, and social class exclusion from higher education in this country. And so if you're an African-American student, you're a Latino student, you're a first-generation college student or you're a woman going into a male-dominated engineering field, for example, it's very reasonable for you to ask, can people like me belong here? That's literally
他们遇到了具有挑战性的事情，他们认为，哦，也许我没有那种似乎是某人做这件事所必需的神奇成分。那个想法是被教给人们的。或者如果你想考虑大学的归属感，在这个国家，高等教育中存在着种族、民族和社会阶层排斥的非常字面的历史。所以如果你是一个非裔美国学生，你是一个拉丁裔学生，你是一个第一代大学生，或者你是一个进入男性主导的工程领域的女性，例如，你问“像我这样的人能属于这里吗？”是非常合理的。这字面上是
coming from the context. So the mind is kind of mediating this, and it's kind of producing this consequence, but it's coming from contexts that have a reality to them. Sometimes a series of negative events is simply a coincidence, bad luck. But when unpleasant experiences cascade into a whirlpool of negativity, it might be because of unconscious thought patterns that are deeply rooted in how we respond to stress and setback. The good news is there are ways to interrupt these cycles. When we come back, how to stop a downward spiral before it takes over your life.
源于背景。所以大脑在某种程度上起到了调节作用，并产生了一种后果，但这种后果源于具有现实意义的背景。有时，一系列负面事件仅仅是巧合或运气不好。但当不愉快的经历演变成负面情绪的漩涡时，这可能是因为我们应对压力和挫折的方式中根深蒂固的潜意识思维模式所致。好消息是，有一些方法可以打破这些循环。稍后回来，我们将探讨如何在负面螺旋失控前将其阻止。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you had the experience of being stuck in a downward spiral where one bad thing led to the next? Have you found ways to pull yourself out of a negative spiral? If you have a story, a question, or a comment that you would like to show, share with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, failure. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Often in life, we take a wrong turn without realizing it. It's easy to keep
您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是香卡·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。您是否有过陷入负面螺旋的经历，即一件坏事导致了下一件坏事？您是否找到了让自己摆脱负面螺旋的方法？如果您有想要与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的故事、问题或评论，请在手机上录制一段语音备忘录，并发送电子邮件至 Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请注明“failure”。再次重申，邮箱地址是 Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。在生活中，我们常常会在不知不觉中走错路。我们很容易继续
walking that path and find ourselves lost in cycles of struggle, self-dive, and self-dive, and and social isolation. Psychologist Greg Walton is the author of Ordinary Magic, the science of how we can achieve big change with small acts. He has spent many years studying how wise interventions at crucial moments can keep us from spiraling downward. Greg, we talked earlier about belonging uncertainty and how it can lead us to jump to negative conclusions that can confirm our fears.
走那条路，发现自己迷失在挣扎、自我怀疑和社交孤立的循环中。心理学家格雷格·沃尔顿（Greg Walton）是《普通魔法》（Ordinary Magic）一书的作者，该书探讨了我们如何通过微小的行动实现巨大变革的科学。他多年来一直致力于研究在关键时刻采取明智的干预措施如何防止我们陷入恶性循环。格雷格，我们之前谈到了归属感的不确定性，以及它如何导致我们得出负面结论，从而加剧我们的恐惧。
One of your studies that has long been a favorite of mine looked at a social belonging intervention among college students who are members of a minority group. Can you describe the challenge that you were trying to address and the intervention that you designed? Sure. So these were African-American students attending a predominantly white selective university. And what we did was to create an experience for the students
您长期以来最受我喜爱的一项研究，考察了少数群体大学生中的社交归属感干预。您能描述一下您试图解决的挑战以及您设计的干预措施吗？当然。这些是非裔美国学生，他们就读于一所以白人为主的精英大学。我们所做的是为学生创造一种体验，
where we shared stories from a diversity of older students about the experience of going to college and the worries about belonging, that come up in that experience. So there were stories from white students and Asian students and African-American students and Latino students. There were stories of academic struggles
我们分享了来自不同背景的高年级学生关于大学生活经历以及随之而来的归属感担忧的故事。其中包括白人学生、亚裔学生、非裔美国学生和拉丁裔学生的故事。这些故事讲述了学业上的挣扎，
and feeling like you were behind academically. There were stories of being excluded from social events. There were stories of having lots of friends, but then maybe not having the close friends that you really want. And we told the participating students who were in the first year of going to college that they were experts in the transition to college.
以及感觉自己在学业上落后的心情。还有关于被社交活动排斥的故事。还有关于虽然有很多朋友，但可能没有真正想要的亲密朋友的故事。我们告诉参加这项研究的大一新生，他们是大学过渡方面的专家。
And we wanted to know, their thoughts about why belonging worries are common as students come to college and how they can get better with time. And we wanted to share their advice with future students so that future students could learn from them. And so we gave students the stories, then we gave them lots of space to tell their own story, to describe why these worries about belonging are normal, how they've experienced them, how they've changed over time. And the whole, the point of all of this was that the goal was that then when students experienced those day-to-day challenges, when you got excluded from a social event, when you just had a bad day, when maybe you got a disappointing mark on a test,
我们想了解他们对于为什么学生刚上大学时会有归属感担忧，以及这些担忧如何随时间改善的想法。我们想与未来的学生分享他们的建议，以便未来的学生能从中学习。因此，我们向学生提供了这些故事，然后给他们充足的空间来讲述自己的故事，描述为什么这些关于归属感的担忧是正常的，他们是如何经历这些担忧的，以及这些担忧如何随时间而改变。这一切的重点在于，目标是当学生经历那些日常挑战时，比如被社交活动排斥，或者只是度过了糟糕的一天，又或者在考试中得到了令人失望的分数，
that you would be able to say, that was unfortunate, that was problematic. I didn't love that, but it doesn't have to mean I don't belong in general in school. It doesn't have to mean that people like me don't belong in general in school. That's the kind of thing that you go through as you go to college. So in some ways, by putting the students in the role of advisors, where they're basically potentially advising future students who come to the college. And they're basically saying, look, you know, I experienced these setbacks in my first few months of being a freshman in college, but it turned out that they were transient. What you're doing is you're helping the students themselves see that many of these setbacks,
你能够说，那是不幸的，那是令人困扰的。我不喜欢那样，但这并不意味着我整体上不属于这所学校。这并不意味着像我这样的人整体上不属于这所学校。这就是你上大学时会经历的事情。所以从某种程度上说，通过让学生扮演顾问的角色，他们基本上是在为未来进入这所大学的学生提供建议。他们基本上是在说，看，你知道，我在大一的前几个月里也经历过这些挫折，但事实证明它们是暂时的。你所做的是帮助学生自己看到，许多这些挫折，
in fact, are transient, that they should not be drawing sweeping conclusions from small amounts of data. Yeah, like when I went to college and I had the in-and-out experience and I felt homesick, I had no idea that maybe the kid from Irvine, too, might be worried about their belonging. Like, I was just all caught up in my head. And the whole process of the transition to college was all about the excitement of going to college. It was all about the opportunities of college. It was all about what an awesome institution it was. There was no allowance for the fact that this is kind of our modern coming of age ritual, that you would have experiences of homesickness, that you would have times that you don't feel so great. You would have times,
事实上，都是暂时的，他们不应该根据少量的数据得出笼统的结论。是的，就像我上大学时，我有过那种进进出出的经历，感到思乡，我根本不知道那个来自欧文的孩子可能也在担心自己的归属感。我当时完全沉浸在自己的思绪中。整个大学过渡的过程完全是关于上大学的兴奋。完全是关于大学的机会。完全是关于这是一所多么棒的机构。没有人考虑到这其实是我们现代的成年礼，你会经历思乡之情，会有感觉不太好的时候。会有一些时候，
you don't feel so connected. There is no allowance that that was normal and that was okay and that that could get better over time. And it's really important to talk about that and to say that and to say that in lots of different ways and have lots of different people say that so that everybody knows when they're going through their own personal journey of that process, that they know that that's normal and that's part of the process and that they can work through that. It doesn't become a TIFBIT. What was the effect on the students of this intervention, Greg? Well, the first thing we did is we looked at their daily diary responses over the next week.
你感觉不到那么多的联系。没有人承认这是正常的，这是可以的，而且随着时间的推移，情况会好转。谈论这一点非常重要，要以多种不同的方式说出来，并让许多不同的人说出来，这样每个人在经历自己的人生旅程时，都知道这是正常的，这是过程的一部分，他们可以克服这些困难。它不会变成一个大问题。格雷格，这种干预对学生有什么影响？嗯，我们做的第一件事是查看了他们接下来一周的每日日记回复。
We asked them every day what good or bad things happened to them. And we also asked them how much they felt like they belonged in school. And what we found is that the intervention didn't change the kinds of daily experiences that students had, but it prevented bad days from having bad meanings. So when African-American students had a worse day over the course of a week, with the belonging intervention, they maintained a sense of belonging. Their sense of belonging didn't drop over that period. And then we found that it translated into behavior.
我们每天询问他们发生了什么好事或坏事。我们还询问了他们感觉自己对学校的归属感有多强。我们发现，干预措施并没有改变学生所经历的日常事件类型，但它防止了糟糕的一天产生糟糕的意义。因此，当非裔美国学生在一周内度过了糟糕的一天时，通过归属感干预，他们保持了归属感。他们的归属感在那段时间里没有下降。然后我们发现这转化为行为。
They were emailing professors more, going to office hours more. They were actually studying more every night. And then we found that it shifted their grades. So their grades got better over time. We tracked students' grades through the end of college and found that the intervention actually reduced the black-white achievement gap by 50% over that three-year period. And the effect was largest senior year.
他们更多地给教授发电子邮件，更多地去办公时间。他们实际上每晚学习得更多。然后我们发现这改变了他们的成绩。所以他们的成绩随着时间的推移变得更好。我们追踪了学生直到大学毕业的成绩，发现该干预措施在三年内将黑人与白人的成绩差距缩小了50%。而且这种影响在大四时最为显著，
where there is a reduction of 80%. And then there were lots of downstream outcomes that were important. People were happier. They were healthier. They're going to the doctor less. And there were benefits that emerged even in adult life. At the average age of 27, people reported higher levels of life satisfaction, higher levels of career success.
减少了80%。此外，还有许多重要的后续成果。人们更快乐了。他们更健康了。他们看医生的次数减少了。而且即使在成年生活中也出现了益处。在平均27岁时，人们报告了更高水平的生活满意度和更高水平的职业成功。
And they reported greater embeddedness in social networks and important relationships. Like they were more likely to have mentors. And those mentors had supported. those changes over time. That's what we call an upward spiral. So it started with the psychology. How do you make sense of this little daily event? It then transfers into a behavior. Okay, that event was bad, but it doesn't mean I have to, I don't belong here in general. I'm going to go join a different club. I'm going to go talk to that professor again. And then you have a relationship where you start to have a community and you have a relationship in a community and
他们报告在社交网络和重要关系中拥有更强的嵌入感。比如他们更有可能有导师。而那些导师支持了这些随时间的变化。这就是我们所说的向上螺旋。所以它始于心理学。你如何解读这个小小的日常事件？然后它转化为行为。好吧，那件事很糟糕，但这并不意味着我必须认为我整体上不属于这里。我要去参加另一个俱乐部。我要再去和那位教授谈谈。然后你拥有了一种关系，你开始拥有一个社区，你在社区中拥有了一种关系，并且
that becomes really consequential. So there's another kind of wise intervention that you call reframing, and there's a story you used to read to your daughter Lucy called One Morning in Maine. Tell me the plot of One Morning in Maine and how it relates to this idea of reframing. Yeah, One Morning in Maine is the classic story from Robert McCloskey, and it's a story of Sal, who's a young child, and she is very eager to go with her father to Buck's Harbor for the day, but she wakes up with a loose tooth. And so she wails to her mama, mama, mama, I have a loose tooth. I have a loose tooth. I'm not going to be able to go to Buck's Harbor with daddy. And her mother then reframes it. She says, oh, when you have a loose tooth, that's when you've become a big girl. And the whole first half of the book or maybe two-thirds of the book is about Sal kind of playing with that idea. So she thinks she asks her mother, did you have a loose tooth when you were a little girl? And her mother says yes. She asks, does baby sisters, Jane's, or her tooth, will she have loose teeth too? And her mother says, not for a long time.
这变得非常有意义。所以还有另一种你称之为“重构”的明智干预，你过去常给女儿露西读一个故事，叫《缅因州的一个早晨》（One Morning in Maine）。请讲讲《缅因州的一个早晨》的情节，以及它如何与这种重构的理念相关联。是的，《缅因州的一个早晨》是罗伯特·麦克洛斯基（Robert McCloskey）的经典故事，讲述的是小女孩萨尔（Sal）的故事，她非常渴望和爸爸一起去巴克斯港（Bucks Harbor）过一天，但她醒来时发现牙齿松动了。于是她向妈妈哭诉，妈妈，妈妈，我有一颗松动的牙齿。我有一颗松动的牙齿。我不能和爸爸去巴克斯港了。她的母亲随后重构了这件事。她说，哦，当你有一颗松动的牙齿时，那说明你已经长大了。书的前半部分或三分之二的内容都是关于萨尔如何玩味这个想法。所以她问母亲，你小时候有松动的牙齿吗？母亲说有。她问，妹妹简的牙齿也会松动吗？母亲说，还要很久。
She's still a baby now. And then she goes to walk on the beach and she wonders whether the birds have loose teeth, whether the seal has loose teeth. And she gets to her father who's digging clams. And she proclaims, I have a loose tooth. I'm becoming a big girl. And her father affirms that interpretation of the event. And then in the sense, the denouement of the story is going to Bucks Harbor and having a great day with her father.
她现在还是个婴儿。然后她去海滩散步，想知道鸟儿是否有松动的牙齿，海豹是否有松动的牙齿。她找到正在挖蛤蜊的父亲，宣布说，我有一颗松动的牙齿。我正在长大。她的父亲肯定了对这一事件的解释。然后，故事的结局是去巴克斯港和父亲度过了美好的一天。
So one morning before school, your daughter, Lucy, sprained her ankle, and she was wailing and didn't want to go to school. I understand that you thought of one morning in Maine as you tried to reframe the situation. Yeah. I mean, we said everybody gets a sprained ankle, and it's not going to be a permanent disability. and it's definitely not a reason not to go to school. I told her stories of my own sprained ankles. My wife, Lisa, told stories of her sprained ankles. And we helped her to see that it was normal.
所以有一天上学前，你的女儿露西扭伤了脚踝，她哭闹着不想去学校。我明白你试图重构这种情况时想到了《缅因州的一个早晨》。是的。我的意思是，我们说每个人都会扭伤脚踝，这不会成为永久性的残疾，而且绝对不是不去学校的理由。我给她讲了我自己扭伤脚踝的故事。我的妻子丽莎也讲了她扭伤脚踝的故事。我们帮助她看到这是正常的。
It was part of being human. And it didn't have to mean anything big. It didn't have to mean that you couldn't engage in the activities and participate in the spaces that you want to participate in. So in some ways, I think what this is doing is it's asking people to reconsider the possibility that the setbacks that they're experiencing are just setbacks and not catastrophes? Yeah, so all the time, I think,
这是作为人类的一部分。它不需要意味着任何重大的事情。它不需要意味着你不能参加你想要参加的活动和空间。所以从某种程度上说，我认为这要求人们重新考虑他们正在经历的挫折只是挫折而不是灾难的可能性？是的，所以我认为一直以来，
that we have these challenges that we face. And when we have a question that's on our mind, those challenges can become catastrophes. So you're struggling with a baby, your baby is colicky, and you're wondering, am I going to be a good parent? And it seems like everything you do
我们都会面临这些挑战。当我们心中有疑问时，这些挑战就会变成灾难。比如你正在为一个婴儿挣扎，你的婴儿有肠绞痛，你心想，我会成为一个好父母吗？似乎你所做的一切
with this colicky baby is not helpful. maybe makes them cry even more, and it seems to confirm in your mind this fear that you might be a bad parent. And that fear is just as toxic as the thought, like, maybe I'm a bad kid, is to a kid. One of the other wise interventions you talk about is the power of surfacing emotions. I understand that you were once visiting a museum in San Jose with your son Oliver. when you had an opportunity to demonstrate this wise intervention. Tell me the story of what happened.
对于这个有肠绞痛的婴儿都没有帮助，甚至可能让他们哭得更厉害，这似乎在你心中证实了你可能是一个糟糕父母的恐惧。这种恐惧和孩子认为“我可能是一个坏孩子”的想法一样具有毒性。你谈到的另一个明智干预是“显露情绪”的力量。我听说你曾经和儿子奥利弗一起参观圣何塞的一家博物馆，当时你有机会展示这种明智的干预。请讲讲发生了什么。
Yeah, it was, the museum was tech interactive, and we had gone through the whole museum. It's a great place, and we had just left, but Oliver was looking at an exhibit just inside the doorway. So the rest of us had just walked outside of the door, and he was still inside looking at this exhibit, and we were waiting for him. And then he burst out, and the tears were streaming down his face,
是的，那是在科技互动博物馆，我们已经参观了整个博物馆。那是个好地方，我们刚离开，但奥利弗还在门口看一个展品。所以我们其他人刚走出门口，他还在里面看那个展品，我们在等他。然后他冲了出来，泪流满面，
and he was crying, and I picked him up, and I hugged him, and then I thought of this word surfacing. I thought to just try to say what it was that I thought he was feeling. So I said, you were scared, you'd be left behind, right? And I could feel him, he nodded, and then I could just feel his body start to relax. It was a way to kind of put the question on the table to say, I see the worry that you have. It's a reasonable worry. worry. And now that we both see it, we can start to let it go. We talked earlier about how negative spirals can become entrenched in our thinking. We develop fears about ourselves and then consciously or maybe unconsciously seek out evidence
他在哭，我抱起他，拥抱了他，然后我想到了“显露”这个词。我想试着说出我认为他当时的感觉。所以我说，你害怕被丢下，对吧？我能感觉到他点了点头，然后我能感觉到他的身体开始放松。这是一种把问题摆在桌面上，说出“我看到了你的担忧”的方式。这是一个合理的担忧。现在我们都看到了它，我们可以开始放下它了。我们之前谈到了负面螺旋如何在我们思维中根深蒂固。我们对自己产生恐惧，然后有意识或无意识地寻找证据
that confirms those fears. These spirals then become false stories that we tell ourselves. You found that having a strong personal narrative can serve as a powerful antidote to this pattern. You have a family story involving your grandmother that gives you a sense of identity. What is this story, Greg? Yeah, my grandmother is someone, this is my father's mother who is very close with. Her name is Vendla. And in retirement in Tucson, Arizona, she wrote and self-published a couple of books, like memoirs of her life, which was quite extraordinary.
来证实这些恐惧。这些螺旋随后变成了我们告诉自己的虚假故事。你发现拥有一个强大的个人叙事可以作为这种模式的有力解毒剂。你有一个关于你祖母的家庭故事，它给了你一种身份感。这个故事是什么，格雷格？是的，我的祖母，这是我父亲的母亲，我和她非常亲近。她的名字叫文德拉（Vendla）。在亚利桑那州图森市退休后，她写并自费出版了几本书，比如她的人生回忆录，这非常了不起。
And she tells the story of how when she was 13 years old, in 1922, she moved with her family from Minnesota to Arizona in a Model T. Ford, how they camped along the way, how they fixed blowouts on the tire, how they homesteaded in eastern Arizona, how they joined the ranching community there. She went to high school, a boarding school in Los Angeles, and then to college and became a teacher, how she taught in one room schoolhouses in Sedona and elsewhere in Arizona, how she met and fell in love with my grandfather, how they settled in Kansas and fought through the dust storms of the Great Depression. It's stories of strength and agency and grit. It's stories of goodness and community and support and neighborliness. And there are stories that she wrote down in these memoirs.
她讲述了1922年她13岁时，如何随家人开着福特T型车从明尼苏达州搬到亚利桑那州，他们沿途如何露营，如何修理爆胎，如何在亚利桑那州东部定居，如何加入那里的牧场社区。她去了洛杉矶的一所寄宿高中，然后上了大学并成为了一名教师，她如何在塞多纳和亚利桑那州其他地方的一室学校教书，她如何遇见并爱上了我的祖父，他们如何在堪萨斯州定居，并度过了大萧条时期的沙尘暴。这些是关于力量、能动性和毅力的故事。这些是关于善良、社区、支持和邻里情谊的故事。这些是她写在回忆录里的故事。
And then there are also stories that she told to me personally. And there are stories that are like built into the environment. So in that old homestead land in Arizona, she as a gift and my grandfather received a small amount of land from the old family ranch. And they hand-built a cabin out of Adobe. It's a cabin with no electricity, no running water. But it's become a place of family virtue. treats and family gatherings, and to me, it represents that strength and that agency and that identity that she has.
还有她亲自告诉我的故事。还有一些故事就像融入了环境一样。在亚利桑那州那片古老的宅基地土地上，她和祖父从老家庭牧场收到了一小块土地作为礼物。他们亲手用土坯建造了一间小屋。那是一间没有电、没有自来水的小屋。但它已经成为了家庭美德的聚集地和家庭聚会的地方，对我来说，它代表了她所拥有的那种力量、能动性和身份。
Can you talk about how you once had a tough time in college and on Thanksgiving break you went to visit your grandmother in Tucson? What happened during that holiday, Greg? Yeah, I mean, college was, you know, discombobulating for me. It felt very far from home, very detached. And so there were several times I took the chance to, instead of going all the way home to Michigan, to go to Arizona and spend time with her in her retirement home,
你能谈谈你曾经在大学里度过一段艰难时光，感恩节假期你去图森看望祖母的事吗？那个假期发生了什么，格雷格？是的，大学生活对我来说很混乱。感觉离家很远，很疏离。所以有几次我抓住机会，没有回密歇根的家，而是去了亚利桑那州，在她退休的家里陪她，
I would sleep on her, pull out sofa. And she would tell me stories of her experiences when she was my age, stories from when she was a boarding school student, and stories from the cabin. And it was a way to reconnect with those, identities. I could see her story and I could see her agency as she took on the challenges as she lived through the Great Depression. And as a young person hearing those stories, I couldn't
我会睡在她那张折叠沙发上。她会给我讲她像我这个年纪时的经历，她在寄宿学校时的故事，以及关于小屋的故事。这是一种重新连接那些身份的方式。我能看到她的故事，也能看到她在面对挑战、经历大萧条时的能动性。作为一个听到这些故事的年轻人，我无法
help but hear them from the perspective of the challenges that I faced. And to think that's how she did it, how could I do it? What's the way that I could do it? How can I be persistent? How can I be kind. How can I reflect those values that are family values? They're not just her values. They're not just my values. There are our values. They're who we are and who we want to be. Here's how she did it. How is it that I could do it? Times have changed. We're not building, you know, complicated train ticket arrangements to get from Kansas to the East Coast anymore. We have airplanes. We have different affordances. But what are the values that are guiding us and how can we use those to navigate our lives today? In addition to the techniques we've discussed today,
不从我所面临的挑战的角度去听。心想她是那样做到的，我怎么能做到呢？我能怎么做呢？我如何才能坚持不懈？我如何才能善良？我如何才能反映出那些家庭价值观？它们不仅仅是她的价值观。它们不仅仅是我的价值观。它们是我们的价值观。它们是我们是谁以及我们想成为谁。她是那样做到的。我该怎么做呢？时代变了。我们不再需要为了从堪萨斯州到东海岸而安排复杂的火车票了。我们有飞机。我们有不同的条件。但指导我们的价值观是什么，我们如何利用这些价值观来驾驭今天的生活？除了我们今天讨论的技术之外，
there's a set of emotional tools that can make a profound difference in helping someone who's spiraling. We talk with Greg about these tools in our companion episode, exclusively on Hidden Brain Plus. If you're a parent or a teacher, or perhaps have a friend or partner caught in a negative thought spiral, you'll definitely want to check it out. If you're already a subscriber to Hidden Brain Plus, that episode is available right now in this podcast feed. It's titled The Best Version of You. If you're not yet subscribed, please go to support.hiddenbrain.org.
还有一套情感工具，可以对帮助陷入螺旋的人产生深远的影响。我们在我们的配套剧集中与格雷格讨论了这些工具，该剧集仅在《隐藏的大脑Plus》上提供。如果您是家长或老师，或者有朋友或伴侣陷入了负面思维螺旋，您一定要去看看。如果您已经是《隐藏的大脑Plus》的订阅者，该剧集现在就在此播客订阅源中。标题是《最好的你》（The Best Version of You）。如果您还没有订阅，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。
If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.com slash hidden brain. You can get a free seven-day trial in both places. Again, that's support. com.hiddenbrain.org or apple.com slash hidden brain. Brain. Greg Walton is a psychologist at Stanford University. He's the author of Ordinary Magic, the science of how we can achieve big change with small acts.
如果您使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.com/hiddenbrain。您可以在这两个地方获得七天的免费试用。再次重申，网址是 support.hiddenbrain.org 或 apple.com/hiddenbrain。格雷格·沃尔顿是斯坦福大学的心理学家。他是《普通魔法》一书的作者，该书探讨了我们如何通过微小的行动实现巨大变革的科学。
Greg, I wanted you to come on the show for many years now. Thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you very much, Shankar. I really appreciate it. It's been a wonderful conversation. Have you had the experience of being stuck in a downward spiral where one bad thing led to the next? Have you found ways to pull yourself out of a negative spiral? If you have a personal story or a question or comment that you would like to share with the Hidden Brain audience,
格雷格，我多年来一直想请你上节目。非常感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢，香卡。我真的很感激。这是一次美妙的谈话。您是否有过陷入负面螺旋的经历，即一件坏事导致了下一件坏事？您是否找到了让自己摆脱负面螺旋的方法？如果您有想要与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人故事、问题或评论，
please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, failure. Again, that's feedback at hiddenbrain.org. When we come back, your questions answered. Listeners share incredible stories of kindness and researcher Abigail Marsh returns to the show to answer your questions about her work on extreme altruism. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
请在手机上录制一段语音备忘录，并发送电子邮件至 Feedback@Hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请注明“failure”。再次重申，邮箱地址是 feedback@hiddenbrain.org。稍后回来，我们将回答您的问题。听众分享了令人难以置信的善良故事，研究员阿比盖尔·马什（Abigail Marsh）回到节目中，回答关于她关于极端利他主义工作的提问。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. When I went to journalism school, many years ago now, I noticed a certain bias in myself and many of my classmates. We wanted to do hard-hitting work, investigations. Some of us were keen to go to war zones and report from the front lines of conflict. All of us lived in dread of being relegated to so-called puff pieces. A lot of stories fell into the puffpiece purgatory. Stories about cute animals.
我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。多年前我上新闻学院时，我注意到自己和许多同学身上有一种偏见。我们想做硬新闻、调查报道。我们中的一些人热衷于去战区，从冲突前线进行报道。我们所有人都害怕被降级去写所谓的“软文”。很多故事都落入了软文的炼狱。关于可爱动物的故事。
Stories about insignificant local events. Stories featuring do-gooders and happy endings. It's this last category that will be the focus of the rest of today's show. One thing I've learned since going to journalism school is that do-gooders and happy endings actually make for great stories. People who are extremely kind and generous can, in fact, be as fascinating as people who are extremely bad. And in a time when so much of the news is disturbing, these stories remind us that kindness and decency are also to be found everywhere.
关于无关紧要的当地事件的故事。关于好心人和圆满结局的故事。正是这最后一类将成为今天节目剩余部分的重点。自从上新闻学院以来，我学到的一件事是，好心人和圆满结局实际上可以成就伟大的故事。极其善良和慷慨的人，实际上可以和极其邪恶的人一样引人入胜。在新闻如此令人不安的时代，这些故事提醒我们，善良和体面也随处可见。
We talked about the heroes who walk amongst us recently with Abigail Marsh. She's a psychologist and neuroscientist at Georgetown University, and she studies extreme altruists. If you missed our first conversation with her, you can find it in this podcast feed. It's the episode titled Radical Kindness. Abigail Marsh joins us again for our latest installment of our segment, Your Questions Answered. Abigail Marsh, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me back. Abby, one of the groups of extreme altruists that you studied in your research
我们最近和阿比盖尔·马什谈到了我们身边的英雄。她是乔治城大学的心理学家和神经科学家，研究极端利他主义者。如果您错过了我们与她的第一次谈话，可以在此播客订阅源中找到。那集标题是《激进的善良》（Radical Kindness）。阿比盖尔·马什再次加入我们，参加我们“回答您的问题”环节的最新一期。阿比盖尔·马什，欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢再次邀请我。艾比，你在研究中研究的极端利他主义者群体之一
are people who decide to donate a kidney to a stranger. And I'd like to start with a message we received after our episode aired. It comes from listener Lucia Lloyd. I really like the things that the episode was saying about how we all want to become more altruistic. And I was particularly affected by the person who, said that he believed that God put us on this earth to help people and wanted to do what God wanted in helping other people. And I thought that's what I believe too. And maybe the obvious answer to how can I be more like the people who donate their kidney to a stranger is for me to donate my
是那些决定向陌生人捐赠肾脏的人。我想从我们节目播出后收到的一条信息开始。它来自听众露西亚·劳埃德（Lucia Lloyd）。我非常喜欢那一集所说的关于我们都想变得更利他的内容。我特别被那个人打动，他说他相信上帝把我们放在这个地球上是为了帮助别人，并想做上帝想做的事来帮助别人。我想那也是我的信仰。也许关于我如何能变得更像那些向陌生人捐赠肾脏的人，最明显的答案就是让我向陌生人捐赠我的
kidney to a stranger. So I got online and started looking for how I could donate my kidney to a stranger. So I got online and started looking for how I could donate my kidney where I live and this morning made an appointment with my doctor to get the blood test that are required to find out my blood type and have a record of that. And so I am already getting started on the process. And it's too soon to know whether I will be accepted to the program, but I hope so. And I wanted to let you know what a positive impact this has had on my life in motivating me, who had never considered donating a kidney before to go ahead and get started in the donation process, and that I might very easily be ending up to save somebody's life because of your episode.
肾脏。所以我上网开始寻找我如何能捐赠我的肾脏。所以我上网开始寻找我如何能在我居住的地方捐赠我的肾脏，今天早上和医生预约了进行所需的血液测试，以找出我的血型并记录下来。所以我已经开始了这个过程。现在知道我是否会被该项目录取还为时过早，但我希望如此。我想让你知道这对我的生活产生了多么积极的影响，激励了我这个以前从未考虑过捐赠肾脏的人去开始捐赠过程，而且我可能很容易因为你们的节目而最终挽救某人的生命。
So that's an incredible story, Abby. I had tears in my eyes when I listened to Lucia's message. I hope she's able to move forward with her donation, and Lucia, please keep us posted if you do. Abby, in your work studying kidney donors, you talked with a woman who was the first known case of what is known as a non-directed donation. What is a non-directed donation, and who was this woman, Abby? First of all, I just want to take a moment to thank Lucia for calling in and telling us her story, and I'm incredibly moved and touched to hear about the effect that hearing about kidney donations had on her. Going back to the very first person that we know of who for sure wanted to donate a kidney to a stranger, her name was Sanyana Graff, or I should say her name is Sanyana Graf. She's still alive.
那真是一个令人难以置信的故事，艾比。我听露西亚的信息时热泪盈眶。我希望她能继续她的捐赠，露西亚，如果你这样做了，请随时告诉我们。艾比，在你研究肾脏捐赠者的工作中，你和一位女性谈过，她是已知的首例所谓的“非定向捐赠”。什么是“非定向捐赠”，这位女性是谁，艾比？首先，我想花点时间感谢露西亚打来电话告诉我们她的故事，听到关于肾脏捐赠的信息对她产生的影响，我感到非常感动和触动。回到我们所知的第一个确定想向陌生人捐赠肾脏的人，她的名字叫桑亚娜·格拉夫（Sanyana Graff），或者我应该说她的名字是桑亚娜·格拉夫。她还活着。
And she had a very unusual story because unlike most of the altruistic kidney donors that I have worked with, whose decisions in part were a response to finding out about somebody else donating, which I think, illustrates the incredible ripple effects that altruism has. She decided to donate, having never known anybody who had done it before. She simply knew that there was a need for kidneys, that it was possible to donate to somebody who was unrelated to you, and she was a mom and a Buddhist religious leader at the time who didn't have a lot of extra time or a lot of extra money to donate. And she thought, you know, I'm somebody who believes helping is an incredibly important part. of a good life. This is a way that I can help. And to her great credit, she was very persistent
她的故事非常不寻常，因为与我合作过的大多数利他肾脏捐赠者不同，他们的决定部分是对发现别人捐赠的回应，我认为这说明了利他主义产生的令人难以置信的连锁反应。她决定捐赠时，从未认识任何做过这件事的人。她只是知道对肾脏有需求，知道向与你无关的人捐赠是可能的，而她当时是一位母亲和佛教宗教领袖，没有太多的额外时间或额外的钱来捐赠。她想，你知道，我是一个相信帮助是美好生活极其重要的一部分的人。这是一种我可以提供帮助的方式。值得称赞的是，她非常坚持
in tracking down a transplant facility that would actually do the transplant because at the time most transplant facilities actually refused to let people donate a kidney to a stranger. So most people are much less generous towards strangers than they are toward close friends and family. And this is a bias that's known as social discounting. But people who engage in extraordinary real-world altruism, like the altruistic kidney donors we've been talking about, showed dramatically reduced social discounting. In your research, you explored various explanations for reduced social discounting among these altruists. What explanation did you rule out, and which one did you settle on, Abby? So in our initial research with altruistic kidney donors,
寻找一家真正会进行移植手术的移植机构，因为当时大多数移植机构实际上拒绝让人们向陌生人捐赠肾脏。所以大多数人对陌生人的慷慨程度远低于对亲密朋友和家人的慷慨程度。这是一种被称为“社会折扣”（social discounting）的偏见。但是，从事非凡现实世界利他主义的人，比如我们一直在谈论的利他肾脏捐赠者，表现出了显著降低的社会折扣。在你的研究中，你探索了这些利他主义者社会折扣降低的各种解释。你排除了哪种解释，最终确定了哪种解释，艾比？所以在我们对利他肾脏捐赠者的初步研究中，
we discovered that they are, unlike most people, very generous to people who they don't well who are very different from themselves, who were even strangers. And that makes sense. If you're willing to give a kidney to a stranger, it makes sense that you don't discount the welfare of very distant others more. The question is why. And I will say there's a lot we still don't understand about why this happens, but there seem to be a couple things in mind. First, at the most sort of simple mechanistic level, it's clear that altruistic kidney donors genuinely place more value on the welfare of other people, all other people, and that the value that they place on others' welfare just doesn't drop off as those people become more socially distant from
我们发现，与大多数人不同，他们对与自己非常不同的人，甚至是陌生人，都非常慷慨。这说得通。如果你愿意向陌生人捐赠肾脏，那么你对非常遥远的他人福利的折扣就不会更多，这很有道理。问题是为什么。我得说，关于为什么会发生这种情况，我们还有很多不了解的地方，但似乎有几点需要考虑。首先，在最简单的机械层面，很明显，利他肾脏捐赠者确实对其他人的福利，所有其他人的福利，给予了更多的重视，而且他们对他人福利的重视程度并不会随着这些人变得在社会上更加疏远而下降，
them, meaning they genuinely believe that what happens to other people matters, regardless of who those other people are. It's possible that you could get an effect like that from people getting better and better at overriding the desire to be selfish as the desire to be selfish grows. And so maybe it could be the case that altruistic kidney donors are just very good at overriding the bias to be selfish when it comes to sharing with strangers. But the brain imaging research we did showed no evidence of that at all. When we asked altruistic kidney donors and typical adults to make decisions whether to be selfish or to share with increasingly distant others during fMRI brain scanning, we found no evidence of activation in any of the brain regions that are associated with overcoming internal biases, including the bias to be selfish.
这意味着他们确实相信发生在其他人身上的事情很重要，无论那些人是谁。人们可能会认为，随着自私欲望的增长，人们越来越擅长克服自私的欲望，从而产生这种效果。所以也许利他肾脏捐赠者只是非常擅长在与陌生人分享时克服自私的偏见。但我们所做的脑成像研究根本没有显示出任何证据。当我们要求利他肾脏捐赠者和典型成年人在fMRI脑扫描期间决定是自私还是与越来越疏远的他人分享时，我们没有发现任何与克服内部偏见（包括自私偏见）相关的大脑区域激活的证据。
Instead, we found patterns of activation in regions like the amygdala and the rostral anterior anterior cingulate cortex that mapped on to the value that the altruists were placing on increasingly distant strangers welfare. Lucia mentioned in her message to us that she believes that God put us on earth to help other people. This brings us to a question that many people raised. Here's a message we received from listener Bob Dean. Hello, my name is Father Bob Dean from Holy Family Church in Duxbury, Massachusetts. And I'm calling to ask the question, is there any correlation between religiosity and one's altruism? What do you think, Abby? The relationship between religiosity and altruism is complex.
相反，我们在杏仁核和前扣带皮层吻侧等区域发现了激活模式，这些模式与利他主义者对越来越疏远的陌生人福利的重视程度相对应。露西亚在给我们的信息中提到，她相信上帝把我们放在地球上是为了帮助别人。这引出了许多人提出的一个问题。这是我们收到的一条来自听众鲍勃·迪恩（Bob Dean）神父的信息。你好，我是马萨诸塞州达克斯伯里圣家教堂的鲍勃·迪恩神父。我打电话来问一个问题，宗教信仰与一个人的利他主义之间有什么相关性吗？你怎么看，艾比？宗教信仰与利他主义之间的关系很复杂。
There's no question that most major. religious faiths place a lot of value on helping strangers with the parable of the Good Samaritan potentially being the most obvious example. Jesus makes it extremely clear in his teachings that all of us have the obligation to care for our neighbor and that neighbor could be anybody including people from groups that we traditionally don't like or even in conflict with. And many other religions have very similar teachings. Buddhism is one, Judaism, Islam, etc. However, However, if you look at altruistic behavior across groups of people, you don't see as strong a relationship as you might expect between either religiosity and altruism or a specific religious faith and engaging in altruistic behaviors, with some exceptions. So, for example, in a faith like Islam where there are certain times of year, where giving to others is sort of the tradition during that time period, you absolutely see big increases in giving.
毫无疑问，大多数主要的宗教信仰都非常重视帮助陌生人，好撒玛利亚人的寓言可能是最明显的例子。耶稣在他的教导中非常清楚地表明，我们所有人都有照顾邻居的义务，而那个邻居可以是任何人，包括那些我们传统上不喜欢甚至与之冲突的群体。许多其他宗教也有非常相似的教导。佛教是一种，犹太教、伊斯兰教等。然而，如果你观察不同人群的利他行为，你并没有看到宗教信仰与利他主义，或者特定的宗教信仰与从事利他行为之间存在你可能预期的那种强相关性，当然也有一些例外。例如，在像伊斯兰教这样的信仰中，一年中有某些时期，给予他人是那个时期的传统，你绝对会看到给予行为的大幅增加。
But over the course of the year, the differences are not that huge. And to the degree that any community creates a division between those who are like us and those who are not like us, that can actually suppress altruism and generosity. And so, unfortunately, there is a tendency in some religious communities, and this applies to many faiths, to make it clear that the people whose outcomes really, matter are the people who follow the same beliefs and traditions we do, and people who don't don't matter. And so that actually suppresses altruism. And so I think there's a lot of sort of competing forces that play into that relationship. My sense is to the degree that your specific religious
但在一年中，差异并没有那么大。如果任何社区在“像我们一样的人”和“不像我们一样的人”之间制造了隔阂，那实际上会抑制利他主义和慷慨。所以，不幸的是，在一些宗教社区中存在一种倾向，这适用于许多信仰，即明确表示那些结果真正重要的人是那些遵循我们相同信仰和传统的人，而那些不遵循的人则不重要。这实际上抑制了利他主义。所以我认为有很多相互竞争的力量在影响这种关系。我的感觉是，如果你的特定宗教
views are consistent with the idea that there is inherent goodness in people and that the average person is worth helping, even if you don't know much about them, then that could create a relationship between religiosity and altruism. One of the messages that you shared with our audience in our initial conversation is that we can all train ourselves to be more altruistic. A listener named Susie had a question that touches on whether the opposite might also be true. Here, Susie. I was in a situation working as a nurse driving home at 3.30 in the morning
观点与“人有内在的善良”以及“普通人值得帮助，即使你对他们了解不多”这一理念一致，那么这可能会在宗教信仰和利他主义之间建立一种关系。你在我们最初的谈话中与我们的听众分享的信息之一是，我们都可以训练自己变得更加利他。一位名叫苏西（Susie）的听众提出了一个问题，涉及相反的情况是否也可能成立。这里是苏西。我当时是一名护士，凌晨3点30分开车回家，
and found a woman in the middle of the road, February, in Denver, Colorado, freezing outside, naked, beaten, and bloody, pulled over, helped her to the side of the road, wrapped her in a warm sleeping bag I had in my car, waited for the ambulance. I was 27 at the time when that happened. Now I'm 60, and I wonder if your migula changes over time. Does the size change? Does experience change that response? Not saying I wouldn't do the same thing today,
在科罗拉多州丹佛市的马路中间发现了一名女性，二月份，外面天寒地冻，她赤身裸体，被打得遍体鳞伤，满身是血，我靠边停车，把她扶到路边，用我车里的暖睡袋裹住她，等待救护车。那时我27岁。现在我60岁了，我想知道你的杏仁核是否会随时间改变。大小会改变吗？经历会改变那种反应吗？并不是说我今天不会做同样的事情，
just wondering if life experience, exposure to fear, changes your reaction over time. Thank you. So Abby, Susie referenced the part of the brain known as the amygdala. In our earlier conversation, we talked about your research finding that people who are unusually caring, and highly altruistic, have larger amygdala's on average,
只是想知道生活经历、对恐惧的接触是否会随时间改变你的反应。谢谢。所以艾比，苏西提到了大脑中被称为杏仁核的部分。在我们之前的谈话中，我们谈到了你的研究发现，那些特别有爱心、高度利他的人，平均拥有更大的杏仁核，
and this might be why they are better able to recognize the distress of other people. What do you think of Susie's question? Can experiencing fear make you more risk-averse? Interestingly, no. There is really cool data, especially from the pandemic, that states of acute stress seem to make people even more likely to help others, which I think is sort of a really wonderful moral, Because I do think compelling works of fiction, like for example, the Lord of the Flies, paint a picture of people just sort of teetering on the brink of civility. And the moment things start to go south and we're all experiencing a lot of fear and stress, we're going to turn on each other. But the reality doesn't seem to bear that out. In fact, there has been a case study of a real Lord of the Flies situation in which a group of boys, I think from Australia, but it was certainly somewhere in the same.
这可能就是为什么他们能够更好地识别他人的痛苦。你对苏西的问题怎么看？经历恐惧会让你变得更加规避风险吗？有趣的是，不会。确实有一些非常酷的数据，特别是来自疫情期间的数据，表明急性压力状态似乎使人们更有可能帮助他人，我认为这是一种非常美妙的道德，因为我确实认为引人入胜的虚构作品，例如《蝇王》（Lord of the Flies），描绘了一幅人们处于文明边缘摇摇欲坠的画面。一旦事情开始恶化，我们都在经历大量的恐惧和压力，我们就会互相攻击。但现实似乎并不支持这一点。事实上，有一个真实的《蝇王》情况的案例研究，其中一群男孩，我想是来自澳大利亚，但肯定是在同一个地方。
South Pacific were cast away, lost on a deserted island. And what actually happened in that situation is they formed a little mini civilization. They took care of each other. They collectively found out ways to get food. And they 100% supported one another until help came for them. And so that's much more similar to what we see in many other real world situations in which groups are under threat is it seems to create a powerful incentive to band together and support one another, not universally, right? And I study the full spectrum of what I call the caring continuum from people who are unusually generous on the one end to people who are unusually callous and even psychopathic on the others. There are always going to be exceptions and people who
南太平洋的人们被困在荒岛上。在那种情况下，他们实际上形成了一个小型文明。他们互相照顾，共同寻找食物，并且在救援到来之前百分之百地支持彼此。这与我们在现实世界中看到的许多其他群体受威胁的情况非常相似，似乎这创造了一种强大的激励机制，促使人们团结起来并互相支持，当然并非普遍如此，对吧？我研究的是我所称的“关怀连续体”的全谱，从一端极其慷慨的人到另一端极其冷酷甚至有精神病态倾向的人。总会有例外，也会有人在危险或压力的情况下利用和剥削他人，但幸运的是，这并不是常态。关于苏西提出的另一个问题，即人们是否会随着生活经历而改变，答案是肯定的。我们的生活经历百分之百地改变了我们。特别是，如果我们经历过压力或恐惧，且无法自救，导致我们感到自我效能感降低，也就是说，我们在那些情况下感到无助。这是基于一些证据的推测，但这可能会导致人们在其他人处于危险时不太愿意伸出援手。但总的来说，当人们处于创伤性境遇并挺过来时，他们，他们，他们
will take advantage of and exploit people in situations of danger or stress, but that luckily is not the norm. As to Susie's other question about whether people change over time in response to life experiences, absolutely. Our life experiences 100% change us. In particular, if we've had experiences of stress or fear in which we have been unable to help ourselves, in which, you know, we feel less self-afficacy as a result, you know, we've been helpless in those situations. This is sort of speculating based on a number of lines of evidence, but that might cause people to be less likely to want to pitch in when other people are in danger. But in general, when people are in traumatic situations and they pull through, they, they, they
走出了困境，实际上能够幸存下来，并且能够承受比他们想象中更多的危险和压力，这增强了他们的自我效能感，实际上使他们在未来更有可能帮助他人。稍后回来，我们将探讨文化如何影响我们慷慨待人的可能性，特别是对待陌生人。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。善良是会传染的。传递下去。你可能听过这句话。这是一种你可能会在交通堵塞时看到的汽车保险杠贴纸上，或者在孩子教室的海报上看到的感言。
come out the other side and they actually were able to survive and they were able to withstand more danger and stress than they would have imagined, it increases their sense of self-efficacy and it actually makes them more likely to help others in the future. When we come back, how culture affects our likelihood to be generous, particularly with regard to strangers. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. Kindness is contagious. Pass it on. You've probably heard that phrase. It's the kind of sentiment you might see on a bumper sticker while in traffic or on a poster in your kids' classroom.
但这真的吗？当我们目睹善良和慷慨的行为时，这是否真的会让我们自己也更倾向于变得善良和慷慨？在思考这个问题时，请听听我们从听众亚当那里收到的故事。他讲述了他女儿刚做完心脏直视手术的那一天。亚当在回家的路上，打算去照顾家里的猫，而他的妻子留在医院陪女儿。他正沿着95号州际公路行驶，这时撞上了一个坑洼，轮胎爆了。下面是亚当讲述的后续故事。我开始尝试拆卸轮胎上的螺母，却发现车上配备的短扳手根本无法拧动螺母。
But is it true? When we witness kind and generous behavior, does it actually make us more inclined to be kind and generous ourselves? As you think about that question, listen to the story we received from listener Adam. He tells about the day his daughter had just had open heart surgery. Adam was on his way home to take care of the family cats while his wife stayed with their daughter. He was driving down Interstate 95 when he hit a pothole and got a flat tire. Here's Adam with the rest of the story. I started to attempt to remove the nuts from the tire only to find that the short wrench I was given with the car was not capable of cracking the nut.
我试了一次又一次，就在我尝试的时候，突然下起了雨。那是压垮我的最后一根稻草。我崩溃了，在高速公路中间情绪失控，完全不顾自己正处于危险之中，周围的车正以极高的速度飞驰而过。我当时一定很引人注目，因为我跳上跳下，对着我的车大喊大叫。就在下一分钟，一辆白色卡车停在我身后，一位绅士从卡车里走出来，他让我想起了篮球运动员丹尼斯·罗德曼，他满身纹身，戴着多个耳环，留着亮橙色的头发。他说，看起来你需要一些帮助。就在那时，我向他倾诉了我的女儿刚做完心脏直视手术，我只想回家照顾动物，结果却发生了这一切。他让我深呼吸，然后走过来试图帮我拧开螺母。他意识到扳手也太短了，就在那时他说，
I tried and tried, and as I was trying, it suddenly started to rain. That was the final straw for me. I snapped and I had a meltdown in the middle of this highway, regardless of the danger I was in with the car speeding by me at very high speeds. I must have been a sight because I was jumping up and down and yelling at my car. within the next minute a white truck pulled up behind me a gentleman got out of the truck who reminded me a lot of the basketball player dennis rodman he was covered in tattoos multiple piercings and bright orange hair he said it looks like you could use some help that is when i unloaded on him about how my daughter had just had open heart surgery and i just wanted to get home and take care of the animals and then all of this happened he told me to take a breath and he came over and tried to help me crack the nut. He realized that the wrench was too short as well, and that's when he said,
这看起来是贝蒂的工作。我看着他，问他，谁是贝蒂？他回答说，贝蒂是我的管钳。贝蒂毫不费力地拆下了那个顽固的螺母。当我们完成后，我开始不停地感谢他，他只是摇了摇头，挥挥手示意我不用客气。当他走开时，他说，
this looks like a job for Betty. I looked at him and I asked, who's Betty? He replied, Betty is my pipe wrench. Betty proceeded to remove that stubborn nut with no problem at all. When we finished, I started thanking him profusely, and he only shook his head and waved his hand to dismiss me. And as he walked away, he said,
你的女儿会没事的。坚强点。她需要你。我永远不会忘记那种善良和勇敢的行为。我真希望知道这个人的名字，这样我就能好好感谢他。我现在能做的最好的事就是感谢贝蒂的力量和决心。所以艾比，我们每周都会在我们的姐妹播客《我未被歌颂的英雄》中讲述这样的故事。所以我们从听众那里得知，他们觉得这些故事非常令人振奋和感人。
your daughter is going to be okay. Just keep it together. She's going to need you. I'll never forget that act of kindness and bravery. I wish I knew this man's name so I could thank him properly. The best I can do now is thank Betty for her strength and determination. So Abby, we feature stories like this every week on our sister podcast, My Unsung Hero. So we know anecdotally from listeners that they find these stories to be very uplifting and very moving.
但我们从科学和神经学的角度了解这些故事如何影响我们吗？当然。那是我听过的最好的故事之一。天哪。我真希望我能亲眼看到。我非常感谢亚当打电话告诉我们发生在他身上的事。这让我产生了强烈的共鸣，因为我年轻时也有过类似的经历，当时我被一个陌生人从高速公路事故中救出，他对我说的第一句话也是“看起来你需要一些帮助”。这真的让我
but do we know from a scientific and neurological perspective about how stories like this affect us? Absolutely. And that is one of the best stories I've ever heard. Oh, my gosh. I just wish I had been able to see it myself. And I really appreciate Adam calling to tell us about what happened to him. And it really resonates with me because of the experience I had when I was younger being rescued from a highway accident by a stranger who's opening words to me were also what looks like you could use some help. It really takes me
回想起来。所以我们从科学上了解到的关于这种经历的是，它们有许多积极的影响。其中之一是感恩，对吧？如果你在别人帮助你之后体验到感恩，这绝对会增加你未来表现出亲社会行为的可能性。它还可能导致一种称为“道德提升”的状态，这正如其名。这是一种由他人的道德善行所激发的积极能量和灵感，这也与增加亲社会行为有关。最后，每次你体验到甚至只是看到别人为他人做善事，它都会改变你对社会规范的看法，对吧？
back. So what we know scientifically about this kind of experience is that they have a number of positive effects. One of them is gratitude, right? If you experience gratitude after somebody having helped you, that absolutely increases your likelihood of behaving prosocially in the future. It also can result in a state called moral elevation, which is exactly what it sounds like. it's the sense of sort of kind of positive energy and inspiration by the moral good deeds of another person that also has been linked to increase pro-social behavior. And finally, every time you experience or even just see somebody do something kind for another person, it changes your sense of what the social norms are, right?
有人会那样做让你觉得，哦，这是人们会做的事情。而我们对所处社会中社会规范的认知，是我们预测各种行为（包括亲社会行为）的最佳指标之一。你在与极端利他主义者的谈话中注意到的一件事是，他们不像我们许多人在日常生活中那样拥有一套所谓的正义系统。我想我们许多人会评估他人并问，你知道，这是一个好人吗？这是一个坏人吗？我们根据对这些人的判断来分配我们的慷慨和同情心。
That somebody would do that makes you think, oh, this is something that people do. And perceptions of what our social norms are in the societies we live in, are one of the best predictors we have of every kind of behavior, including pro-social behavior. One of the things that you have noticed in your conversations with extreme altruists is that they don't have a sort of justice system that many of us do as we are walking around. So many of us, I think, evaluate people and ask, you know, is this a good person? Is this a bad person? And we sort of meet out our generosity and compassion based on our judgments of these people.
你发现非凡的利他主义者通常认为，无论道德缺陷如何，他人都值得帮助。你能谈谈这个想法吗，艾比？当然。当我们采访利他主义肾脏捐赠者和对照组关于捐赠决定时，那些不是利他主义肾脏捐赠者的人，当我们问为什么他们没有做出捐赠给陌生人的决定时，尽管知道外面有人可以通过肾脏捐赠挽救生命，他们通常会谈论诸如害怕手术，或者，你知道，生活中没有时间。但另一件经常出现的事情是，他们担心捐赠的另一端的人可能不是一个好人，可能不是一个真正值得陌生人捐赠肾脏的人。而这在与我们合作过的利他主义肾脏捐赠者中从未出现过。他们从不说，嗯，我有点担心那个得到
You found that extraordinary altruists often believe that others deserve help regardless of their moral shortcomings. Can you talk about this idea, Abby? Absolutely. When we've interviewed both altruistic kidney donors and controls about decisions to donate, people who are not altruistic kidney donors, when we ask why they haven't made a decision to donate to a stranger, knowing that there are people out there whose lives would be saved by the donation of a kidney, they are. often we'll talk about things like being afraid of surgery or, you know, not having the time in their lives. But another thing that comes up a lot is that they're worried that the person on the other end of the donation might not be a good person, might not be a person who really deserves a kidney from a stranger. And A, that never comes up among the altruistic kidney donors that we've worked with. They never say, well, I was a little worried that the person who got
我肾脏的人不是个好人。事实上，当我们深入探讨这个话题时，我们问，嗯，你有没有担心过谁会得到你的肾脏？普遍的共识是，没有人坏到不值得活下去，或者他们是谁来决定某人是好人还是坏人，我认为这与他们的整体谦逊相一致，这是我们发现非常利他的人所共有的品质之一。他们不认为自己有权决定谁坏到不值得活下去。
my kidney wasn't going to be a good person. And in fact, when we probe them on this top We ask, well, were you ever worried about who might get your kidney? The general consensus is that there's nobody who is so bad that they don't deserve to live, or who are they to decide whether somebody is a good person or a bad person, which I think is in keeping with their overall humility, which is one of the qualities we found very altruistic people share. They don't believe themselves to be in the position of determining who is such a bad person that they don't deserve to live.
我们在《隐藏的大脑》中经常谈论社会规范以及它们如何塑造我们是谁以及我们如何行事。这是我们从听众安娜那里收到的一条信息，她说她来自一个极其利他的家庭。所以首先，我的一生中，我的家人，我的妈妈和姐姐，我的哥哥和我，都竭尽全力去帮助别人，无论是靠边停车帮助陌生人启动他们的车，还是有一次我带回了一个我在酒吧外发现哭泣的女孩。而且我住在路易斯安那州的新奥尔良，那里到处都是利他主义者。我不确定这是否是因为，你知道，这里发生的灾难。比如卡特里娜飓风，当然，但最近还有艾达飓风，城市确实不得不相互依赖并共同努力。但我一直看到人们在帮助陌生人。
We talk a lot on Hidden Brain about social norms and how they shape who we are and how we behave. Here's a message we received from listener Anna, who says she comes from an extremely altruistic family. So first of all, my entire life, my family has gone out of their way, my mom and my sister, my brother and I, to help other people, whether that be pulling over to help strangers jump their car or the time that I took home a girl that I found crying outside of a bar. And then I live in New Orleans, Louisiana, which is full of altruistic people. And I'm not sure if it's because of, you know, the disasters that have happened here. Like Katrina, of course, but more recently Ida, where the city really had to depend on each other and work together. But all the time, I see people helping strangers.
当我听你的关于利他主义者的播客时，这让我大吃一惊，原来不是每个人都是这样的。所以我怀疑这是否是因为我的杏仁核。也许我来自一个拥有大杏仁核的家族。总之，我喜欢你的播客。谢谢。我不得不说，大杏仁核听起来像是摇滚乐队的好名字，艾比。所以安娜的信息提出了许多关于先天与后天以及他人在塑造我们行为中所扮演角色的问题。
And when I listen to your podcast about altruistic people, and it just kind of blew my mind that not everyone is this way. So I wonder if it is because of my amygdala. Maybe I come from a long line of big amygdalas. Anyway, I love your podcast. Thank you. I have to say that the big amygdala sounds like a great name for a rock band, Abby. So Anna's message raises lots of questions about nature versus nurture and the role that other people play in shaping our behavior.
科学对于利他行为在多大程度上受到周围人行为和规范的影响有什么说法？还是说这完全是因为来自一个大杏仁核的家庭？我希望我们有更好的数据来回答这个问题，但我们确实有一些。首先，我们知道总的来说，人格特质是由我们的基因和环境共同塑造的。几年前在《自然评论遗传学》上发表了一项巨大的研究，研究了所有人类人格特质和所有其他人类生物医学特质。
What is the science have to say about the extent to which altruistic behavior? is shaped by the behavior and norms of the people around us? Or is it all about just coming from a family of big amygdala? I wish we had better data to answer this question, but we do have a little bit. First of all, we know that in general, personality traits are shaped by both our genetics and our environments. There was a huge study published in Nature Review genetics several years ago that looked at all human personality traits and all human other biomedical traits.
当谈到人格特质时，平均而言，它们大约一半由基因塑造，一半由环境力量塑造。而且，你知道，这真的并不令人惊讶。这当然是我们看到的在关怀谱系另一端的特质。所以那些有精神病态倾向的人，或者非常冷酷的孩子，我们看到大约一半的变异也是由遗传学解释的，另一半由环境力量解释。所以据我们所知，这对于非常利他的人来说可能也是如此。有趣的是，杏仁核的大小也大约有50%是由遗传因素决定的。所以人们杏仁核的变异大约有一半是遗传的。所以如果你来自一个非常利他的家庭，你可能确实得到了一些利他基因
and when it came to personality traits, on average, they were shaped about half by genes and about half by environmental forces. And, you know, that's really not that surprising. That's certainly what we see for traits at the other end of the carrying spectrum. So people who were psychopathic or children who were very callous, we see that about half of that variation is also accounted for by genetics and the other by environmental forces. So to the best of our knowledge, that's probably also true for being very altruistic. The size of the amygdala, interestingly, is also about 50% accounted for by genetic factors. So variation across people's amygdala is about half genetic. So if you come from a family of very altruistic people, you probably did get some altruistic genes
从他们那里。然而，很难将其与这样一个事实区分开来：你也是在一个环境中长大的，在那里你可能经常观察到人们帮助他人，这会改变你对社会规范的看法。你有许多帮助他人的机会，并发现这有多么令人振奋。所以如果你在生命早期没有机会帮助他人并学习帮助他人带来的所有回报，那种行为和那种动机
from them. However, it's very hard to tease that apart from the fact that you were also raised in an environment where you probably observe people helping others a lot and it would change your perception of social norms. You had many opportunities to help people. and discover how reinforcing that is. And so if you don't have opportunities to help other people early in life and learn all the rewards that come from helping other people, that kind of behavior and that kind of motivation
就不会像你有那些机会时那样根深蒂固。我想谈谈历史模式以及我们对慷慨和善良的态度，特别是对陌生人的态度是如何演变的。这是我们从一位名叫黛博拉的听众那里收到的关于此的信息。我是婴儿潮一代。
will become as ingrained as if you do have those kinds of opportunities. I'd like to talk about historical patterns and how our attitudes about generosity and kindness, particularly to what strangers have evolved. Here's a message we received about that from a listener named Deborah. I am a baby boomer.
我们这一代人，我们见证了民权和国际人权的扩张。二战后美国对我们以前的敌人日本和德国提供的令人难以置信的帮助。非营利组织和慈善事业的扩张，为各种人、问题、动物权利甚至植物和环境权利提供的法律倡导，以一种普遍的方式对我们星球的利他主义。所以黛博拉接着说，她认为美国出现了这种趋势的逆转。有证据表明群体随着时间的推移会变得更善良或更不善良吗，艾比？
My generation, we saw the expansion of civil rights and international human rights. The incredible help that the U.S. gave to our former enemies, Japan and Germany, after World War II. The expansion of non-profits and philanthropy, legal advocacy for all kinds of. of people and problems and animal rights and even the rights of plants and the environment, altruism towards our planet in a general way. So Deborah goes on to say that she thinks that there has been a reversal of this trend in the United States. Is there evidence that groups can become more or less kind over time, Abby?
当然。绝对存在代际差异，通常不像人们想象的那么大。很难区分所谓的，你知道，队列差异——即特定的一群人在其整个生命周期中与年龄相关的差异，对吧？我们确实知道，人们在中年时比年轻时变得更利他和慷慨，这是相当一致的。所以看起来像是婴儿潮一代利他和慷慨的影响，部分原因在于他们目前处于晚年，比如说，这通常，特别是当人们保持健康时，是生命周期中一个异常利他的阶段。让我担心的是，我们看到人际信任、普遍信任的水平在下降，再次强调，是对美国各队列中人们普遍可信度的信念，目前20多岁的一群人拥有有记录以来最低的人际信任水平，我相信，在过去几十年里。现在，有趣的是，婴儿潮一代并不是
Certainly. there are definitely generational differences generally not as big as people think it's very hard to tease apart what are called you know cohort differences so a particular group of people is different across their whole lifespan from age related differences right and we do know that people become more altruistic and generous in middle age relative to when they are younger and that's pretty consistent and so partly what may seem like an effect of the boomer generation being altruistic and generous is the fact that the they are currently late middle age, let's say, which is in general, especially when people are remaining good health, an unusually altruistic point in the lifespan. The thing that does concern me is that we are seeing declining levels of interpersonal trust, generalized trust, again, a belief in the trustworthiness of people in general across cohorts in the United States with a current group of 20-somethings having the lowest levels of interpersonal trust that have been recorded, I believe, in the last multiple decades. Now, interestingly, the boomers were not the
最信任的一代。他们之前的一代人拥有更高水平的人际信任，但水平似乎确实在下降。人们显然一直在争论为什么会这样。这是一个非常令人担忧的问题，因为毫无疑问，信任周围的人是良好社会的基础。我还应该提到我绝对喜欢的一篇论文，我相信是两年前发表在《自然》杂志上的，名为《道德衰落的错觉》。这是一种全世界范围内的队列感知，即现在的情况比我们个人年轻时更糟。每个人都相信这是真的。无论实际数据如何显示，它似乎完全脱离了
most trusting generation. The generations before them had even higher levels of interpersonal trust, but the levels do seem to be going down. And people have been debating, you know, why this is, obviously. It's an issue of a huge amount of concern because having trust in the other people around you is the basis of a good society without question. I should also mention one other paper that I absolutely love that was published in nature, I believe, two years ago, called the illusion of moral decline. This is a universal all around the world cohort-wide perception that things are worse now than they were when we personally were young. Everybody believes that this is true. It doesn't matter what the actual data show. It seems to be completely untethered
实际趋势。原因可能归结于基本的认知偏差，对吧？有某些类型的记忆很容易留在脑海中。我们作为人在年轻时是不同的，对吧？我们有不同的大脑，导致不同类型的记忆留存，包括我们童年时期非常积极的记忆。这就是为什么我们都倾向于认为我们个人在14或15岁时出现的音乐和电影是最好的。它们是最好的吗？也许是，也许不是。但对我们来说它们是最好的，因为我们当时是那样的人。所以世界各地各个年龄段的人都相信现在的人更糟，道德相对于他们年轻时已经衰落了。
to actual trends. And the reasons are probably due to basic cognitive biases, right? There are certain kinds of memories that stick easily in minds. We as people were different when we were young, right? We have different brains that cause different kinds of memories to stick, including really positive memories from our childhood. It's why we all tend to think that the music and the movies that came out when we personally were 14 or 15 years old are the best. Were they the best? Maybe, maybe not. But they were the best to us because of who we were. And so people everywhere all around the world of every age believe that people are worse now, that. that morals had declined relative to when they were young.
所以黛博拉的看法可能真的只是与人们所拥有的更广泛的认知倾向有关。稍后回来，极端利他主义与讨好型人格。我们探讨慷慨行为的局限性，以及在不被他人利用的情况下变得更利他的方法。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。
And so it's possible that Deborah's perception is really just related to a much broader sort of cognitive tendency that people have. When we come back, extreme altruism versus people-pleasing. We explore the limits of generous behavior and ways to become more altruistic without being taken advantage off by other people. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们生活中都认识一些试图从我们这里尽可能多地索取的人。俗话说，得寸进尺。当你天生心地善良、慷慨大方时，很容易被利用。每次我们被剥削，我们可能会在我们慢慢建立的围墙上增加一块砖。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. All of us know people in our lives who are going to try and take as much as they can get from us. Give them an inch and they'll take a mile as the saying goes. When you're naturally kind-hearted, and generous, it's easy to get taken advantage of. And each time we get exploited, we might add a brick to the walls we slowly build around ourselves.
我们说销售人员不可信，因为我们曾经在买车时吃过亏。我们在约会软件上遇到一个混蛋，告诉自己爱情是给傻瓜的。我们与老板有过一次糟糕的经历，就开始相信所有的老板都是骗子。一块砖接一块砖，我们的围墙变得越来越大，越来越高。虽然这种反应可能是自然的，但它几乎保证了未来的不快乐。那么，我们如何在保护自己免受少数伤害我们的人的同时，保持对周围人的开放和慷慨呢？
We say that salespeople cannot be trusted because we once got burned buying a car. We meet a jerk on a dating app and tell ourselves that love is for suckers. We have one bad experience with a boss and come to believe that all bosses are charlatans. Brick by brick, our walls grow bigger. and taller. While this response might be natural, it pretty much guarantees future unhappiness. So how can we remain open-hearted and generous with the people around us while protecting ourselves from the few who would do us harm?
心理学家和神经科学家阿比盖尔·马什在乔治城大学研究利他主义。她是《恐惧因素：一种情绪如何连接利他主义者、精神病态者以及两者之间的所有人》一书的作者。艾比，我想给你播放一条我们从一位名叫弗朗西斯科的听众那里收到的信息。我想讲述我邻居的故事。她的名字叫珍妮丝。她可能快70岁了，
Psychologist and neuroscientist Abigail Marsh studies altruism at Georgetown University. She's the author of The Fear Factor, how one emotion connects altruists, psychopaths, and everyone in between. Abby, I'd like to play you a message we received from a listener named Francisco. I wanted to tell the story of my neighbor. Her name is Janice. She's probably close to her 70s,
但她是我认识的最活跃的人。她是泥瓦匠出身，在建筑行业工作。她是我认识的最慷慨的人。她利用自己的时间，无论是否空闲，确保每个人的草坪都定期修剪。她为我们街上的几乎每个邻居拉出垃圾桶。她不断地查看你的情况，总是主动提供帮助。我总是告诉她，她是随我们房子而来的最好的东西。
but she's the most active person I know. She's a bricklayer by trade, and she works in construction. And she is the most generous person I know. She uses her time, spare or not, to make sure everyone's lawn is moaned on a regular basis. She pulls out trash cans for pretty much every neighbor in our street. She keeps checking on you and is always offering to help. And I always tell her she's the best thing that came with our house.
在这一点上，她几乎成了我们家庭的一员，我们将永远感激她的慷慨。所以艾比，珍妮丝显然是非凡的，但有没有可能不择手段的人会利用她的慷慨？你听说过极端利他主义者被他人剥削的故事吗？没有你想象的那么多。我听说过几个。
At this point, she's pretty much become a member of her family and we'll be eternally grateful for her generosity. So Abby, Janice is clearly extraordinary, but is it possible that unscrupulous people might take advantage of her generosity? Have you heard stories of extreme altruists being exploited by other people? Not as many as you might imagine. I've heard a few.
确实有几个例子，因为如果你更利他，你确实倾向于对人性有更积极的看法，并假设大多数其他人是值得信任的。当你开始信任别人时，有时其他人会利用你的信任。但有趣的是，非常利他的人似乎并没有对被他人剥削表现得更不敏感。他们同样可能通过撤回对那个人的信任，甚至以社会可接受的方式进行报复来做出反应，他们并不是软柿子或受气包。我认为这是一个非常重要的区别。我合作过的一些非常利他的人
There have been a couple instances where people who do, right, because if you are more altruistic, you do tend to have a generally more positive view of human nature and an assumption that most other people are trustworthy. And when you start out trusting people, sometimes other people are going to exploit your trust. But interestingly, it doesn't seem to be that very altruistic people are less sensitive to being exploited by other people. And they're just as likely to respond by withdrawing trust from that person or even retaliating in socially acceptable ways, it's not like their pushovers or dormats. And I think that that's a really important distinction to draw. And some of the very altruistic people I've
曾在执法部门工作。他们，你知道，是受过勋章的退伍军人。他们通常是非常坚强的人。他们在商业领域工作。他们处于，你知道，真正必须准确理解人性的职位。但我认为区别在于他们从个别剥削实例中吸取的教训。如果你有愤世嫉俗或焦虑的倾向，你可能会太快地从某人剥削你或可能只是没有回报你的慷慨的例子中得出结论，哦，你不能信任人作为一条规则。我认为不那么快地得出这个结论通常是一件好事。因为是的，看，外面确实有剥削性的人。毫无疑问。在我的工作中，我们发现，你知道，百分之几
worked with have worked for law enforcement. They've, you know, been decorated military veterans. They're often very tough people. They work in business. They're positions, you know, where they really have to understand human nature accurately. But I think the difference is the lessons they draw from individual instances of exploitation. If you have a tendency towards cynicism or anxiety, you might be too quick to learn from one instance of somebody exploiting you or maybe just not reciprocating your generosity that, oh, you can't trust people as a rule. And I think it's generally a good thing not to be too quick to learn that. Because yes, look, there are exploitative people out there. There's no question about it. In my work, we find that, you know, a couple
的人口有临床水平的精神病态。不幸的是，精神病态之所以如此难以检测，是因为具有这些特质的人倾向于伪装。他们倾向于表现得像非常好的人，这样你就不知道他们是谁。这可能导致一些人对人产生普遍的焦虑和不信任感。然而，作为一个不信任的人，我们从关于囚徒困境等范式的几十年研究中知道。如果你不愿意向他人延伸信任，总的来说，你会发现从长远来看你会输，因为你合作和扩大蛋糕的机会更少。我们从几位听众那里收到的问题之一是我们如何识别
percent of the population has clinical levels of psychopathy. And unfortunately, the reason psychopathy is so hard to detect is because people with these traits tend to mask. They tend to act like really, really nice people so that you don't know who they are. And that can lead some people to feel just generally anxious and untrustworthy around people as a rule. However, not being a trusting person, we know from decades of research on paradigms like the prisoner's dilemma. If you're unwilling to extend trust to other people, in general, you find you lose in the long term because you have fewer opportunities to cooperate and expand the pie. One of the questions we received from several listeners is how we can recognize the
健康慷慨与不健康讨好型人格之间的界限。这是听众蒙特塞拉。我是那种不能说不，总是帮助每个人的人。我曾多次让人践踏我。直到现在，我一直认为我只是一个好人，当有人利用我的慷慨时，我并不太在意。我基本上喜欢那样的自己。然而，最近，话语变了，像我这样的讨好者被分析为由于某种童年创伤或环境而具有某种共依赖性或缺乏健康的自尊。做一个太好的人已经变成了一种病态。我想我的自尊现在很健康，
boundary between healthy generosity and unhealthy people-pleasing. Here's listener Montserra. I am one of those people who cannot say no and always helps everyone. And I have let people walk all over me several times. Until now, I always thought that I was just a good person and it did not bother me much when someone took advantage of my generosity. I basically like myself like that. Lately, though, the discourse has changed and people pleasers like me are analyzed as having some kind of codependency or lack of healthy self-esteem due to some childhood trauma or circumstance. Being too good a person has become a sort of pathological condition. I think my self-esteem is healthy now,
尽管我承认我年轻时确实缺乏自尊。所以，艾比，关于界限以及如何为自己设定健康界限的想法是这些天时代精神中的一部分。人们如何在保持不被剥削的界限的同时向他人展示慷慨？好问题。首先，这确实有一点TikTok和Instagram心理学的味道，这是这些天所有学术心理学家的祸害。很难消除外面所有糟糕的模因。
although I recognize that I did have a lack of self-esteem when I was younger. So, Abby, the idea of boundaries and how to set healthy boundaries for yourself is something that's in the zeitgeist a lot these days. How can people show generosity to others while maintaining the boundaries that keep them from being exploited? Great questions. First of all, this does have a bit of the ring of TikTok and Instagram psychology, which is the scourge of all academic psychologists these days. It's just so hard to stamp out all the bad memes out there.
而且，你知道，不幸的是，那种在社交媒体上被传播的，你知道，深奥、讽刺的引语中的心理智慧，会让每个不讨人喜欢的人都成为自恋者，每个令人不快的经历都成为创伤，每个分歧都成为煤气灯效应。而且，你知道，我认为记住这一点很重要，许多在网上心理学领域的有影响力的人可能实际上并没有关于他们正在谈论的主题的太多深层知识。这个讨好者的概念，我认为听起来有点像那种思维方式。认为那些对他人善良和慷慨的人一定是因为他们是讨好者。这是你能对这种行为做出的最糟糕的解读，这与你在社交媒体上听到的许多心理学相一致。
And, you know, unfortunately, the kind of psychological wisdom in deep, ironic quotes, that gets perpetrated on social media, you know, would have every disagreeable person being a narcissist and every employee. pleasant experience being a trauma and every disagreement being gaslighting. And it's, you know, I think it's important to remember that a lot of people who were influencers in the psychology space online may not actually have that much deep knowledge about the topics they're talking about. And this people pleaser concept, I think, sounds a little bit like that vein of thinking. The idea that people who were kind and generous to other people must be doing it because they're people pleasers. It's the worst possible spin that you could put on this kind of behavior, which is in keeping with a lot of the psychology you here touted on social media.
我会说，代表利他主义者的特质与那些因为利他主义以外的原因而表现得好的人的特质之间是有区别的。我们从人格评估中知道，有两种亲社会特质在表现方式上是不同的。你可能听说过大五人格特质。大多数人都熟悉它们，尽责性、外向性、开放性、负面情绪和宜人性。宜人性与冲突回避联系得更紧密，对吧？你不喜欢制造波澜。你不喜欢让人们心烦。这是一种可能与讨好型人格相关的特质，特别是如果它源于，例如，
I will say that there's a difference between the kinds of traits that typify altruists and the kinds of traits that do typify people who are nice for reasons other than altruism. And we know from assessments of personality that there's sort of two kinds of pro-social traits that are different in the way that they manifest. And you may have heard of the big five personality traits. Most people are familiar with them, conscientiousness, extroversion, openness, negative emotionality, and agreeableness. Agreeableness is much more closely associated with being conflict-averse, right? You don't like to make waves. You don't like to upset people. And that is a trait that can be associated with people-pleasing, especially if it's derived from, for example,
拥有糟糕的自我形象或者只是对人们生你的气感到非常不舒服。这并不是特别符合真正利他主义的特质。非常利他的人更有可能在第六种主要人格特质上得分很高，这种特质不太为人所知，称为诚实-谦逊。而诚实-谦逊与听起来一样，是谦逊的，这并不是低自尊。谦逊是对自己有准确的感知，并且不太受他人愤怒或情绪的影响。当你是一个谦逊的人时，你的自我感会更稳定一点。
having a poor self-image or just being very uncomfortable with people being mad at you. That's not particularly a trait that is consistent with true altruism. Very altruistic people are much more likely to be high in the sixth, the major personality trait, which is much less well known, called honesty, humility. And honesty, humility is associated with just like it sounds being humble, which is not low self-esteem. Humble is having an accurate perception of oneself and being less affected sort of by other people's anger or emotions. Your sense of self is a little bit more stable when you're a humble
而且诚实-谦逊也与真正更关心他人的福利相对于你自己的福利有关。所以当诚实-谦逊得分高的人帮助别人时，是因为他们真正重视他们的福利，而不是因为他们认为帮助会如何影响他们个人。当帮助是高宜性的结果时，它可能源于害怕人们不喜欢你或不想让人们生气。无论哪种方式，帮助行为都是好的，但我认为人们思考一下会很有帮助，嗯，我是因为我真正关心他们而帮助别人，而它如何影响我个人根本不是我在考虑的事情吗？还是我因为害怕他们不喜欢
person. And honesty, humility is also associated with genuinely caring more about others' welfare relative to your own. And so when people who are high in honesty, humility help people, it's because they genuinely value their welfare, not because of how they think helping will affect them personally. When helping as a result of high agreeableness, it may be deriving from a fear of people not liking you or not wanting people to be mad at you. And the helping behavior is good either way, but I think it would be helpful for people to think, well, am I helping people because I genuinely care about them and how it affects me personally is just not what I'm thinking about? Or am I helping people out of a fear that they won't like
我或他们可能会生气而帮助别人？那是不同的事情。我们的一些听众问到了作为极端利他主义后果的倦怠风险。我们收到了听众艾琳的这条信息。我对利他主义者、同情心以及在没有简单解决办法的持续情况下的同情疲劳感到好奇。我是一名教师，经常有学生处于各种不理想的家庭和家庭状况中。当我停下来考虑这些中的任何一个时，它都会压垮我。它完全淹没了我的情绪，所以我把这些隔离开来，尽量不去想它。这让我感到冷酷和无情。
me or they might get angry? And that is a different thing. Some of our listeners asked about the risk of burnout as a consequence of extreme altruism. we receive this message from listener Erin. I'm curious about altruists, compassion, and compassion fatigue in ongoing situations without an easy fix. I am a teacher and often have students in a variety of less than ideal home and family situations. When I stop to consider any of these, it crushes me. It completely overwhelms me, so I compartmentalize this and try not to think about it. That leaves me feeling callous and uncaring.
利他行为是什么样的？当其他人处于持续的、令人心碎的、确实没有解决方案的情况时。所以，艾比，像艾琳这样处于没有快速或简单解决办法的情况的人，如何保持那种同情心而不感到精疲力竭？这很难。我合作的利他主义者，他们众多幸运品质之一是，他们能够帮助别人，对吧？他们确定了一个需要帮助的人，他们能做些什么，
What does altruistic behavior look like? like when others are in ongoing, heartbreaking situations that really don't have a solution. So, Abby, how do people like Erin who are in situations without a quick or easy fix maintain that compassion without feeling burned out? It's hard. The altruist I work with, one of their many fortunate qualities, is that they have been able to help somebody else, right? They identified a person that was in need, something they could do about it.
他们确实帮助了那个人。在绝大多数情况下，捐赠进行得很顺利，他们能够感受到这种令人难以置信的替代性快乐和满足感，因为对另一个人的生活产生了如此有意义的影响。有很多需要帮助的人的情况，解决办法并不那么直接，对吧？也许我们根本帮不上忙，或者我们能帮忙的方式很小。当他们真正关心那些受苦的人，并且在日复一日地目睹他们处于痛苦中时，他们理所当然地感到强烈的同情性痛苦，这会导致人们经历很多痛苦。所以我不会假装那种情况有什么简单的解决办法。但大多数人在这种情况下建议的是，尽你
they did help the person. In the overwhelming majority of cases, the donation goes well, and they get to feel this incredible vicarious joy and pleasure of having made such a meaningful impact on another person's life. There are a lot of cases of people in need where the fix is not that straightforward, right? Maybe we can't help at all, or the ways that we can help are small. And this can lead people to experience a lot of distress when they really care about the people who are suffering, and they understandably feel a strong sense of empathic distress when they're witnessing them in distress day after day. So I'm not going to pretend that there's some sort of easy fix to that sort of situation. But what most people recommend in cases like that is to try
最大的努力专注于你能做的事情，对吧，不要让自己被世界上你无法解决的无数问题所淹没和淹没，对吧？我们任何人都可能随时屈服于此。事实上，我认为这是社交媒体将整个世界的问题日复一日地带到我们的电脑屏幕或手机屏幕上的真正危险之一，对吧？世界上没有我们无法理解、无法了解并对其感到替代性痛苦的问题。而人类大脑根本不是为了那样做的。所以我认为我们所有人都有必要有一种谦逊感，即我们无法解决世界上的问题。我们中没有一个人能做到。但我们能做的是找到可处理的局部问题，我们可以找到
your best to focus on the things that you can do, right, to not let yourself get swamped and drown in the enormity of the number of problems in the world that you can't solve, right? Any of us can succumb to that any time. And in fact, I think it's one of the real dangers. of social media bringing the entire world's problems onto our computer screens or our phone screens day after day, right? There's no problem in the world that we can't understand and find out about and feel a sense of vicarious suffering about it. And the human brain was just not meant to do that. And so I think it's important for all of us to have a sense of humility that we cannot fix the world's problems. Not any one of us can. But what we can do is find tractable local problems and we can find
我们可以提供帮助的情况，并尽量专注于这些。这通常是我建议做的。不要去想所有你无法提供帮助的方式。我知道说起来容易。但是，你知道，当涉及到帮助焦虑症患者时，这也是基本的临床心理学。就像，是的，外面有无数潜在的问题。如果你关注的是这些，你就会一直感到焦虑。你只需要训练自己养成专注于你能解决的事情和你能更有把握的事情的习惯。我认为这可能也是这种情况下的最佳建议。你知道，古希腊人对爱有不同的词，艾比。你知道，有一种爱我们可能
situations where we can help and try to focus our best on those. And that's usually what I recommend doing. Don't think about all the ways you can't help. And I know it's easy to say. But, you know, this is basic clinical psychology when it comes to helping people with anxiety as well. It's like, yes, there's an innumerable number of potential problems out there. And if that's what you're focusing on, you will be anxious all the time. And you just have to train yourself to get in a habit of focusing on the things that you can fix and the things that you can be a little bit more confident about. And I think that's probably the best advice in this situation, too. You know, the ancient Greeks had different words for love, Abby. You know, there's a love that we might
对伴侣或孩子感到。还有，你知道，我们可能对一般人感到的无条件的、无私的爱。他们称之为“圣爱”（agape）。当你谈论你研究过的非凡利他主义者时，我突然想到，这可能是一个非常好的词来描述他们对整个人类所体验的那种爱？我认为这是描述他们对人类所感受到的爱的最准确的词。我确实相信真正利他的人在某种深层层面上爱所有人。我知道说出来听起来有点异想天开，或者可能有点矫情，但我真诚地相信，去关心一个你从未见过的人的福利
feel for a partner or for a child. And there's also, you know, the unconditional, selfless love that we might feel for people in general. They called it agape. And as you're talking about the extraordinary altruists that you've studied, it strikes me that that might be a very good word to describe the kind of love that they experience for humankind as a whole? I think it's the exact right word to describe the love that they feel for human kinds. I do believe that truly altruistic people love on some deep level, all people. And I know that sounds a little bit fanciful or maybe a little bit treakly to say, but I genuinely believe that to care about the welfare of somebody that you've never met
之前是一种非常深刻和深远的爱。这不是只有圣人或超级英雄才能达到的，但我认为普通人实际上能够达到那种状态。阿比盖尔·马什是乔治城大学的心理学家和神经科学家。她是《恐惧因素：一种情绪如何连接利他主义者、精神病态者以及两者之间的所有人》一书的作者。艾比，非常感谢你回到《隐藏的大脑》来参与我们听众的想法和问题。这是一种荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。
before is a very deep and profound form of love. And it's not something that only saints or superheroes are able to attain, but I think ordinary people are actually able to achieve that state. Abigail Marsh is a psychologist and neuroscientist at Georgetown University. She's the author of the Fear Factor, how one emotion connects altruists, psychopaths, and everyone in between. Abby, thank you so much for coming back to Hidden Brain to engage with the ideas and questions from our listeners. It's been a pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果关于极端利他主义的对话对你有所启发，请务必查看我们的姐妹播客《我未被歌颂的英雄》。你可以在大多数播客应用程序或我们的网站 hiddenbrain.org 上找到它。
Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If our conversation about extreme altruism was inspiring to you, be sure to check out our sister podcast, My Unsung Hero. You can find it in most podcast apps or on our website at hiddenbrain.org.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，如果你喜欢这一集，请与几个朋友分享。口碑推荐是大多数听众找到我们节目的方式。谢谢，很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
I'm Shankar Vedantam, and if you like this episode, please share it with a few friends. Word of mouth recommendations are how most listeners find our show. Thanks and see you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，如果您喜欢这一集，请分享给几位朋友。口碑推荐是我们大多数听众发现我们节目的方式。谢谢，我们很快再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击逐字稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。